I'm seeing a lot of these high-profile
Lefty accounts say that Twitter's over
that the the party is done Elon is
panicking everything's falling apart and
they're all Jumping Ship heading over to
Mastodon or tribal social and it's funny
because uh you know Ron Perlman and a
couple other actors were like I'm
leaving this platform and then a day
later they're like just popping back in
to say you know elon's a bad dude
they'll be back
because Elon Musk Twitter they've
announced record growth 15 million new
daily active views or some of the
biggest the websites ever seen if not
the most growth in a month they've ever
seen and uh Elon Musk is reinvigorating
the platform people all of a sudden want
to be back on it so as we see people
like Ethan Klein and Kathy Griffin
Banned permanently for violating terms
of service of course they're crying and
screaming saying Twitter's all over man
no one's going to use it it's gonna be
really funny though because uh these
actors they all in this big wave started
impersonating Elon Musk with verified
accounts so he started locking their
accounts because that's always been
against the rules these people are
saying that's it we're gonna have to go
to Mastodon because no one's going to be
here anymore yet the platform's growing
regular people not the cult they're
taking back public discourse on Twitter
so I'm excited to see so far what Elon
has done of course I mentioned Ethan
Klein has been banned the H3 well just
the h3h3 uh Productions Twitter account
Kathy Griffin and then a bunch of actors
and actresses have claimed like we're
ditching whatever we don't want to be
here anymore here's the funny thing I
think it's a scam I think a bunch of
these celebrities were using fake had
fake followers because the big PR stunt
these companies have always done stuff
like this they want to make it look like
you're more prominent
if Elon Musk comes in and starts purging
all the fake accounts how many followers
are going to be lost by these big
celebrities it'll be really embarrassing
so what do you do the smart people are
like I'm leaving for unprincipled give
me press before it becomes embarrassing
so we'll talk about that and then of
course ladies and gentlemen the only
story that I actually care about because
it's mystical and it's magical is the
Maga Moon Rising
I want you all to hear this
at 1202 a.m Pacific Standard Time when
the contiguous United States is now
completely within November 8th the day
of the midterm there will be a beginning
again at 1202 a.m a blood moon a full
moon total blood lunar eclipse it's when
the moon starts turning red
for those on the East Coast between 5 17
and 6 45 or so you will see a blood red
moon
now the Incans and the Mesopotamians
believed that a Blood Moon signified the
death of the king and the overthrow of
his regime I kid you not
this is crazy so that that one has meal
just like you know I don't know I don't
know if I believe in the Omens or
anything but the overthrow of the king
Revolution a red wave perhaps not of
establishment Republicans but of Maga
Republicans so people are calling it The
Maga Moon we'll talk about that plus all
the absurdities man we've got Democrats
contradicting themselves of course with
the left saying where my free speech
it's going away but yeah yeah you never
cared before and then we have fetterman
suing over uh you know ballots are
trying to get counted there's a lot of
stuff going on we're going to talk about
so before we get started my friends head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you at
11 or so p.m you're not going to want to
miss this one because the day before the
election so
we're gonna go ham with it for sure and
talk uh totally uncensored not family
friendly uh friendly that'll be 11 p.m
and then tomorrow we're doing an
extended
show I mean we're gonna be live for a
long time we may go live at 6 p.m we
really got to figure it out just go
early and just have the Stream Run as we
hang out and watch the election results
but before we uh one more thing I will I
will add to my friends head over to
losing my mind.com we could really use
your support on this one we launched an
overtly political song genocide on
Friday this is the most important week
as we you want to get as many sales and
Views as possible so that you hit the
Billboard charts that first week is is
so important if you uh go to
losingmymind.com you can check out the
song on any one of these platforms but
really buying it on the iTunes Store or
anywhere it's 69 cents it really really
helps because because sales are huge
and uh the song is uh mocking The
Establishment corporate press outright
we have them singing for us check out
the music video and uh here's a little a
little snippet you can just see there's
there's me Tucker facing at Taylor
Lorenz it's very very fun as she sings
about how she lies to manipulate people
ah it's all good fun we've got a bunch
more stuff in the works so I really do
appreciate everyone who supported this
song uh so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends joining us today
to talk about this and so much more we
have of course Libby hey Tim what's
going on I don't need to say your last
name anymore I have a last name it's one
of these one no my God I want to name
people one name people nope nice to see
you guys thanks it's Libby Emmons that's
it but you're here so much yeah that's
it also Ian is not here tonight we have
Owen Cook what's up guys who are you
um I do seminars all over the world we
do them completely for free we've done
live events in 265 cities 75 countries
around the world hundreds of thousands
of people face to face and millions
online
um and then we post them on YouTube it's
about personal growth making more money
getting better socially getting more
spiritually tapped in right on
hey guys my name is here if we are
change.org and I know everyone's talking
about the midterm elections right now
but I want to come out officially right
now and I would like to endorse for
2024. my candidate of choice ligma
Johnson he is an individual that is that
has a lot of stiff competition but he's
gonna he's gonna be very hard on the
issues that matter and he's going to win
a lot of hearts and Minds if you are on
the ligma Johnson train you could
officially get this political shirt on
the best politicalshirts.com ligma
Johnson 2024. and I'm search.com you
know what it is
man I I would I would love to just start
with the blood moon story because I love
the weird creepy stuff but let's let's
let's let's get into the nitty-gritty of
Elon banning all these people and record
growth from The Verge ah yes the verge
of all websites they're a lefty website
Twitter tells advertisers that user
growth is at an all time at all-time
highs under Elon Musk and then they add
but will that be enough for advertisers
to come back yeah it's it's pointless
you don't need to ask that question
since musk's takeover Twitter's
monetizable daily users has a growth has
accelerated to more than 20 percent
while Twitter's largest market the US is
growing even more quickly according to
an internal fact obtained by The Verge
that was shared with Twitter's uh sales
team on Monday all right that's the news
right there but this is why it's
important because right now we are
seeing a bunch of leftists these these
people who go on Twitter and just scream
all day they're getting banned Kathy
Griffin's gone this guy a rich Summer is
gone Sarah Silverman backed down I love
this these people who are like screw you
Elon I'll do whatever I want well a
bunch of them went nuts Ethan Klein
Kathy Griffin for instance defied
warnings and impersonated Elon Musk with
a verification badge which has always
been against the rules and they're gone
bye-bye you're out of the conversation
now look
that's not the end of their careers of
course I mean Kathy Griffin maybe she
had nothing left to begin with nobody
wants to hire her all she really has her
Twitter but you know Ethan he hosts a
podcast so he'll be able to keep working
he's just out of the Twitter space Sarah
Silverman she posted that she was locked
out of her account and then quickly
obeyed the rules and then started saying
what Elon Musk was doing if true would
actually be very very amazing so I find
this to be quite hilarious that uh all
their huffing and puffing it's it's not
working in fact Elon Musk taking over
has made Twitter bigger better yeah by
the way Elon just tweeted a couple
minutes ago quote Twitter usage is at an
all-time high LOL and then goes on in a
sub tweet saying I just hope the servers
don't melt now a lot of people are
bringing up the controversy when it
comes to the Banning of a lot of these
celebrities who again didn't didn't
follow the rules were warned and they
still decided to kind of push the limits
here but at the end of the day I
definitely disagree with Kathy Griffin I
definitely disagree with h3h3 but at the
end of the day I hope there is some
Redemption for these individuals but
some some people are are thinking that
this is going to be a larger strategy
when it comes to bringing back a lot of
different people so other people are
saying that this could be potentially 4D
chess as a way to bring back the
unbanned people and not have as much
controversy and try to appease some
people by saying you know what I'll
bring back h3h3 but also so does Alex
Jones you know I'll bring back Kathy
Griffin But but so will of course the
Babylon be and then of course have a
have a kind of concerted strategic
effort on Banning people I think that's
what might be happening here yeah I mean
musk clearly wants to bring all these
people back on the platform he clearly
wants Babylon B and all these guys back
he's just got to like figure out how to
do it to not lose everybody and I think
that he's not going to lose everybody I
think advertisers are going to jump back
on they're going to make a ton of money
this way advertisers don't care we know
they don't care it's obvious they don't
care during pride month when they have
like all their big flags and they have
trans everything and they're super
stoked about that all over the
anglosphere and then you look at their
advertising in Saudi Arabia and it's
just black and white yeah no Pride
anywhere you know they don't care they
just want to go where the money is and
honestly that is what they should be
doing they should be accountable to
their shareholders and that's what they
should do No Quarter
No Quarter for these leftists on Twitter
no look look if you come today put them
all on if you come to me oh so Sargon uh
Carl Benjamin gets banned and they all
say well he broke the rules he deserves
to be banned and it's like he got banned
for uh sarcastically insulting white
supremacists or neo-nazis or whatever he
was calling them a racial slur this was
Twitter so not the YouTube thing he was
calling them so yeah anti-semitic sir
and I I could be wrong it's been a long
time but his his point was like he was
calling them what they hated as a way to
like demean them because he doesn't like
that kind of stuff they banned him he's
leftists then I'll say good riddance
good good good and so they're okay with
censorship they don't agree with free
speech now that Elon Musk is in charge
and saying here are the rules and
they're whining and complaining there is
absolutely no way I will defend people
think about how mean it would be to
actually try and get them back on the
platform that means they come out and
say I believe in these values and then I
go no no I'm going to reject your values
and apply different values to you no no
no no no no they don't want free speech
I will not defend their free speech
that's exactly what they want and what
they believe in that means permanent
bands for all of these people Ethan
Klein Kathy Griffin don't care goodbye
Ethan Klein has praised cancel culture
he's praised Bannings before Kathy
Griffin of course okay then guys live by
you reap what you've sown yeah
I disagree too because the thing is like
the reason you have values isn't because
you want you know you have values
because you hold them across the board
for everybody you don't have you don't
apply your values uh you know based on
what the other people believe it's like
if somebody believes in euthanasia and
you're a doctor and you don't believe in
euthanasia you're not going to help if
if there's a bunch of houses and we all
agree okay if a house starts on fire we
will all come together to help with the
fire out and rebuild the home for you
because we're in this together and then
a fire starts and one guy sits back
laughing and we're like hey you can help
us like no I don't care it's good the
fire is burning and I'll be like okay
dude whatever then one day his house on
fire goes help help my house is on fire
I'm gonna sit back and be like bro you
ain't getting anything from me I'm not
gonna sit here and give give all of my
good will to people who exploit it now
yeah that means your about your values
don't mean anything it absolutely does
it absolutely does we've had this
conversation quite a bit about defending
free speech and for a long time I said
well you know what when when these
people advocate for the destruction
section of the public discourse we must
still defend their free speech no no no
no no when someone comes and says I
don't like what you said I don't want
you to say it and we argue about it that
that's that's that's fine but if someone
is actively destroying everything yeah
I'm not gonna defend them they they
agree they believe in this they agree
with it you see you see my point I see
there's agree with it there was a period
where
you know on this show and on other shows
we've talked about it's like no no no
you know I know these people they they
add no because what ends up happening is
every single time these people advocate
for things to get worse and they do and
then what did we keep doing put it
sitting down crossing our lives like no
no we have to be fair Rick Santorum came
on the show and said we can't impeach
Joe Biden we have to be fair and it's
like dude the guy committed crimes he's
like we don't play those games I am sick
of this I am done with it I believe in
free speech for people who agree and
with free speech if if you if you
believe I should have a right to speak
and you should have right to speak then
I will stop anyone from censoring you
because you are actively participating
and making things better but if you're
the arsonist go around burning down
houses then I Say No Quarter for you get
that out these are destructive people
who are burning everything down what if
the Fire gets too crazy and it affects
your house that's another analogy here
and and I and I do believe uh Biden
should be absolutely impeached and I
absolutely disagree with every thing I
think I think some of their behavior was
absolutely disgusting especially Kathy
Griffin with the the Trump mask the
Trump head that was absolutely uh that
immoral issue yeah the issue is they
were actively getting people banned and
now when when the rules are applied to
them and get this Elon changed the rules
for these people that also pissed me off
the rules have always been if you're
verified you cannot impersonate people
what did Elon say I'm changing the rules
for all of these unhinged leftists
you're now allowed to do it so long as
you put parody in your name and they
still wouldn't do it so they got banned
well these are these are this is not so
much even about the analogy of people of
someone refusing to help with with you
know my house is on fire and he won't
help no no this is the guy who set the
fire these are people who went around
actively attacking the right of speech
if that is your principles I say you
live by them and I'm not gonna defend
you Kathy Griffin wants to post a
picture for what Trump said I will
defend her right when they try to censor
her she actively encourages censorship
I'm going to say you live by the sword
congratulations I think everyone
deserves a Road to Redemption I totally
agree I I think you know they should be
able to be be able to be a part of the
conversations they should of course not
be permanently banned from ever being on
a platform that is a major communication
Highway that we should understand where
their voices are coming from in order to
battle their bad ideas because if we
just shun them to the side they're going
to grow in Fester I agree I get Megan
Murphy back on the platform yeah I I
agree however I will not in any way lift
a single finger to help them that's it
you know I'm listening to this I agree
with both of your points like I see
where you're coming from and I see where
you're coming from I'm gonna need like a
couple days to think about this because
you both make great points it's um do
you think there's any chance that Ethan
could come around based on this
experience or you think he's too
stubborn one more time sorry um could
Ethan come around on the idea of free
speech based on this experience could
this be eye-opening for him perhaps
um he praised cancel culture so whenever
whenever negative thing things are
applied to him he talks about how he's
an advocate for free speech when bad
things happen other people he talks
about how you're being held to certain
standards and facing consequences it's
nonsense it's hypocrisy so look well
he's a smart enough guy to become
successful right so maybe he'll come
around I'd be interested to see if he
has a different perspective after this
and he's made videos about me by the way
and I've never minded that but I'd be
curious to see if he comes around based
on this could be a teacher I I doubt it
he's saying uh Elon Musk killed comedy
dude broke the rules defied the warnings
broke the rules again and now he's yeah
it's a stunt but I'll tell you the way I
see this is we're part of a big
Community we agree with the principle of
free speech people like this have lied
cheated and stolen their way to gain
followers and gain power their
principles Flicker and blow with the
wind and it is completely meaningless
what they say so when they come out now
and say no no I'm for free speech I'll
be like listen I'm going to hold you to
the standards you asked me to hold you
to if someone if if somebody was in my
house and they kept smashing things I
would kick them out but then but you're
making them homeless you're making them
so what you were smashing things up I
don't want people to be homeless I think
people you know should should have a
chance but at a certain point someone is
so destructive chaotic that you just say
I'm not doing it if Kathy Griffin got
banned for just the Trump head I'd be
like no no no no no I I I it's that's a
really really dangerous path to go in
that kind of art but I don't think we
should be banning that the difference
here is these are people who actively
fight against free speech and I'm at the
point where I'm like yo I'm not gonna
let arsonists in my house if we're all
in agreement that we shouldn't commit
arson we are good because you can make a
campfire you're not doing arson you go
to my house start setting fires I'm not
going to sit here and be like nah it's
all right I believe in the people have a
right to to be warm it's like no that's
totally different there's a difference
it's just look I don't know about that
analogy I mean I don't I don't know
there's a lot of analogies here that we
can interpret in many different ways you
sit back and let people constantly smack
you in the face
and then when you say stop they go
They're going around punching people
another analogy for you and then you
just say like well I don't believe in
violence so we're gonna let him keep
doing it it's like no way dude well
that's the password you arrest them
right
pacifist view as if somebody's attacking
you you don't attack but words aren't
violent so so listen by all means I
thank Ethan and Kathy Griffin have a
right to speech I think that them
getting banned was actually kind of dumb
Elon should just lock their accounts
until they change it and then lock it
again until they change it as if you
can't and they take away the
verification badge another thing can do
is if you change your name and parody
someone your icon changes to a gesture
cap permanently so if Kathy Griffin
wants to parody Elon she gets a
permanent gesture cap however I will not
advocate for nor lift a finger for these
people to get their accounts back or
just put a notice underneath their
profile hey guys these guys impersonate
other individuals be careful if they
might be scamming or something like that
yeah yeah or something like that so they
have the candidate tag put a parity tag
under their name the first time they do
it and forever that's it so do you feel
that it should be permanently banned or
that they should do that other solution
that you said I think if you change your
profile to impersonate someone without
labeling it parity they should first
lock your account and say as a verified
account you can impersonate change your
profile picture and your name or add
parity to your account and apply the
gesture icon and then if you say no you
can go back to being your regular
verified self if you then keep doing it
then they then Twitter forcibly puts the
parity under your name permanently and a
gesture icon
but there's nothing wrong with that if
you're an actual comedy account I
thought that was a great suggestion so
do you think that they should be left
banned or do the suggestion that you
said there so Justin I said but I'm I'm
I will never if I ever see Elon Musk not
a single word will be muttered of these
people in any way to bring their
accounts back I'm not going to do it I'm
not going to advocate for arsonists to
be restored do I think they deserve free
speech Yes will I defend anybody who
fights for free speech Yes but I'm done
letting arsonists run amok and then
acting like oh I'll say it again when
Rick Santorum said we can't impeach Joe
Biden because we we are better than that
I'm like dude they are running rough
shot over you right now they have
arrested and charged a bunch of
pro-lifers meanwhile right now there are
protesters at Amy Coney Barrett's out
house maybe not right now but in the
past day or so there's there's a clear
problem of double standards here and I'm
not gonna sit back and just be like well
you know I am I'm going to consistently
apply my values to evil people who are
burning things out hey comparing uh
someone or someone's argument to a Rick
Santorum argument is a low blow first of
all that's not fair he's not a man of
the people and I definitely disagree
with him
um I don't know he's a very weird
politician but but again Main Line
middle of the road I I think again the
criticism of him is absolutely fair I
don't I don't know I don't think it
could be attributed to this larger
conversation let's let's do this we'll
get into it here's a tweet from pop
crave
pop crave's got 1.1 million followers
and they said Twitter suspends Ethan
Klein despite him following Elon musk's
stated guideline for parity accounts
that is a lie that is absolutely not
true across the board all of these
different websites are lying about why
uh these people why Kathy Griffin and
Ethan Klein are being banned this is
what I'm saying I'm I'm I'm not NPR lied
about that I was listening report this
morning on that Ethan Klein banned after
mocking Elon Musk over verification
Fiasco they were banned because they
changed their images and names to Elon
Musk without putting parity in their
name now here's what pisses me off Elon
gave them special rules
why
so Milo got his verification removed
because he put BuzzFeed news reporter in
his profile malianopoulos and then he
was complaining about like why was
everyone's like well you put BuzzFeed
reporter they said you're not verified
then
the rules on Twitter are that you cannot
be verified and be parody
that's just always been that way Elon
decided to make special rules to allow
the left to do this so they could make
fun of him and they intentionally broke
the rules now maybe 40 chess he said I'm
gonna get him I'm gonna give them what
they ask for and they'll still reject it
he gave him warnings they rejected it so
these people don't want to be on the
platform they don't want to have their
accounts restored
these are these are these are people who
are engaged in outright
twit social media arson and the media is
lying on their behalf well they are yeah
there is there is definite lying going
on about this NPR was saying that people
were banned for having parity accounts
which was exactly untrue as well and uh
yeah do you think that musk just thought
that these people have him over a barrel
or something I mean he should clearly
not think that now that the platform is
growing so much but he knew that he's
he's got all the data he knows the he
knows the growth that's happening and
he's he clearly doesn't care he's
tweeting at people eight dollars eight
dollars of the new learn to code right
yeah he's been doing that good man you
know there's that uh that that Viral
Carl popper I mean you ever see it where
he's like the little comic book and he's
like if you tolerate intolerance that
intolerance takes over it's like okay
for you I will apply those standards but
for nobody else so if these people like
Ethan want to say it is good that people
are banned I'll say that when you're
banned so be it congratulations is what
you asked for this is also a difference
in ideology towards the world in general
right so some people believe in firm
boundaries and Order and some people
believe in not feeding reactive energy
right and it's just two different
paradigms of approaching the same
problem and I've seen both things work
I've seen it to where if you put a firm
boundary it actually helps things and if
you don't have a boundary things go to
chaos but I've also seen it to where if
you forgive somebody and you say Hey you
know maybe get them to come around you
know maybe Ethan could come around like
like where where do you get to the point
that somebody see this even comes around
you don't but then this is the problem
with this is that the dude has been
involved in so many high-profile
cancellations and advocated for so much
yeah that when you come into the
conversation late you're like maybe we
can turn them around it's like bro he's
made videos about me I never minded it
but the point is is that you know I can
see the gray area to any human being and
he's a very intelligent person and his
buddy Hassan's intelligent person
they're also very angry people I
disagree with most of what they say but
there their minds are sharp so they
might be able to see things a different
way it'd be amazing if you guys could
have more conversations see you're
filling in for Ian very very well here
so we've had this conversation way too
many times especially with Ian because
it's like no matter how many times an
evil person does something evil and
refuses an olive branch you know Ian is
always he's a good-hearted guy he's
always just like we got to give him a
chance and I'm like at a certain point
dude what would it take to get you guys
into the conversation you mean when I
invite them on the show consistently all
the time in good faith well they're
they're better and they use that to gain
followers and make up fake drama to make
it seem like I pulled some BS dude the
moment you tweeted them something nice
they use it for for views and they make
drama it's just out of the question I
didn't be an amazing conversation like
do you ever make it to L.A or they could
make it out here oh come on come on bro
like we've invited this guy on so many
times Ethan uh uh we I've invited Ethan
I think once or twice outright ignored
Hassan actually agreed and then
privately dm'd and said I I won't do it
I'm sorry and I'm like okay my son's got
a lot of Courage I mean he debated uh
outright said he will never do it really
I'm surprised by that I'm I'm not like
is it because they want you to go to Los
Angeles no it's because if you go to La
they're going to decline dude oh wow I
can't keep having this conversation okay
like we have invited all of these people
consistently and and what they do
invariably is you send an email where
you're like we'd love to have you on the
show and if it's common polite it's
typically ignored sometimes they'll then
screenshot it post it and be like they
invited me but then started calling me a
racial slur it's just like right the
moment you open up communication they're
like now's my chance to get views now's
my chance to make drama ooh they want to
talk to me let's make drama out of it
yeah there's no point well that's been a
lot of this whole Twitter thing is
making drama that's all it is you know
it's like or all the people who are
saying that they're leaving the platform
and they make giant big shows about
leaving the platform it reminds me of
like several years ago when people would
leave Facebook they'd be like I can't be
on Facebook anymore I just can't handle
it anymore and then it'd be like two
weeks later and they're just like hi I'm
back on Facebook it's like you gave me a
whole song and dance about how you were
leaving now you're back to a loser Elon
shut it give them warnings they defied
those warnings and intentionally got
banned and then started doing a PR run
of Elon Musk is is targeting me and they
don't believe in free speech that's why
I'm like no quarter because I believed
in free speech for these people over and
over and over again and every time I did
they turned it around as a PR stunt and
I'm like okay at a certain point you
have to recognize evil people are lying
to you that's it stop helping evil
people that's it help good people who in
good faith are censored when someone
comes out and says I if someone came out
and said I don't believe in free speech
and then got censored I'd be like okay
that person shouldn't have been censored
if someone comes out actively trying to
get people banned celebrating their
Bannings and says no one should ever be
allowed back on I'd be like okay well
that happens to you I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna defend you that's it
yeah there you go well I wasn't going to
go out there advocating for people but
I'd be happy to have everybody back on
the platform
um at this point it's like like yeah you
want to hear what they have to say yeah
why not like just have everybody on
Twitter whenever people are censored
they usually Double Down they're usually
forced into more kind of extremist
corners on the internet and they usually
never have even a pathway towards seeing
any kind of other semblance in any other
side of the story I don't know I might
be too optimistic but I think at the end
of the day bring everyone back let's
have a conversation and let the best
ideas beat out the bad ideas and I think
that's gonna happen and I think that's
the strategy here and and right and no
one disagrees with that and we got a
good super chant the Super Chat that
makes a great example a great analogy
a battle is being fought but but between
two ideological opponents one side
continually insists if we have The High
Ground we must seed to the lower ground
and evil battle even Battlefield with
our enemies it's only fair and the right
thing to do and they say thank you and
then they start shooting at you again
yeah so it's like dude take The High
Ground
I'm done with this
people want free speech to navigate
each and have disparate opinions and and
anger opinions and bad opinions and
leftist opinions I don't care if Elon
Musk ban someone literally because they
were making fun of him I'd be like that
is BS but these are people who are lying
the media is lying they're claiming they
were banned for making fun of Elon Musk
total lies
they're saying they filed the rules
total lies they are setting fire to the
system and hoping we give them an
opportunity to come back I'm not doing
it
anyway Whoopi Goldberg and what's her
name Gigi Hadid delete their Twitter
accounts yeah
isn't she a supermodel yes I don't care
these people are all leaving and Twitter
is growing more than it's ever grown
more and more people want to be on the
platform Elon Musk is making it funny
exciting and entertaining again and
these people are just like well I'm
leaving good so be it I don't care bye
so that this is the point Kathy Griffin
and Ethan Klein wanted to get banned
like along with all these other actors
they're intentionally leaving the
platform because you think that their
follower accounts are fake no I think
for a lot of them it's true like a lot
of high profile celebrities you ever
notice they'll tweet and get like five
retweets they'll get like they have a
million followers and nobody nobody ever
interactions could I speak on that by
the way I live in Los Angeles I live um
right in the epicenter of this so I'll
meet the people they actually approach
me and offer to me to boost uh my
followers I say no because I think it'll
mess up your engagement but
um they'll point out to me all the
people who they've actually boosted
their followers it's apparent it was
very very common for a long long time oh
really to have people like come in fake
followers fake engagement they'll even
get it to the point where they increase
the followers that increase the views on
the videos increase the likes increase
the comments and you can tell the
comments are very dumb and kind of
simple
um this is a huge huge thing they do it
because they're trying to get Social
proof
um some they do yeah well that's what
celebrities do just to make yourself
look more popular more relaxed that's
what celebrities do now what politicians
do is even double layered layered than
that because they're using tax dollars
for Bots and sock puppet accounts in
order to of course Galvanize political
stances and ideas that they want you to
believe that other people are behind as
well so this happens big major level
this is where Elon Musk is smart in 2011
there were Revelations leaked leaked
Communications show that the US
government was purchasing sock puppet
accounts to manipulate public opinion
they claimed not in the United States
nonetheless Twitter was heavily involved
so Elon probably looked at this and said
the intelligence agencies really want
these accounts they want to manipulate
they have no choice but to pay me eight
bucks per account they use so he says
eight bucks
now it's funny because all these
leftists are like there's only 400 000
verified uh individuals anyway even if
Elon Musk charged them all eight dollars
he wouldn't make enough to run the
platform and it's just like are you
stupid yeah he wants to charge people
who are not verified to become verified
so that he gets millions of Eight dollar
subscriptions but more importantly the
US government will now have to spend
eight dollars per bot and they probably
operate billions of them so elon's like
hey but here's the worst part that's my
money that's your money yeah yeah Elon
what it's a government taking our money
and giving it to Elon Musk well yeah I
mean that's that's pretty much his
history when you look at all the
businesses he started number one but but
you know as we talked about celebrities
having social proof the government I
think their proof is called like MK
Ultra proof or something but but they do
this on such a grand level and we are
literally at the precipice where all of
this could be exposed all of the
manipulation all the finagling all the
things that are happening behind the
scenes that we don't know about when it
comes to the big government putting
their hand up your you know what in in
your business that could all end with
Elon Musk saying okay I'm going to make
a stand here fake accounts fake Bots not
allowed here which is going to really
change the internet landscape as as of
course social media has become so
curated the algorithms are so controlled
that it's only what special interests
want you to see when we have free speech
when we don't have Bots we have the
first potential for actual real
conversations to happen that could
change not only the social landscape but
the political landscape of this country
and change it for what I believe to be
for the better since good ideas will be
able to battle battle uh bad ideas and I
think this has been happening on such a
big level especially during the last
three years especially during covet all
the bad ideas that that were followed
that people were going along with could
never be tested and challenged now the
government's going to face a reality
that they can't lie to us anymore and
that's going to be a game changer I
think they're going to keep lying to us
anyway but not on social media
if you guys have seen the article by
Darren Beatty from revolver.news about
Elon on musk and Twitter have you guys
seen those Darren Beatty on
revolver.news he wrote both
um these incredible articles about how
for Elon Musk to buy Twitter is not like
buying Home Depot so even if Home Depot
is theoretically bigger Twitter is this
you know entire National conversation so
it's Elon is probably going to get take
so many hits based on this and there's
so many vulnerabilities that Elon has so
it's going to be tough for him I think
to make this truly free speech I think
it's I think it's still up in the air if
he's able to do this I think it's I
think it really is funny when you think
about the government sock puppets that
you know elon's businesses are all about
subsidy SpaceX government contracts what
what a Tesla they got subsidies or what
yeah especially when it comes to carbon
credits that they also sell on the
market right now that's one of the ways
that they still make a lot of their
money people don't understand that Elon
Musk is also for carbon tax also for
world government and uh you know
promotes a lot of the bigger globalist
issues as well the real dispute is that
the people complaining about Elon are
actually government sock puppets being
like we don't want to spend the eight
dollars as they buy us Tesla that's
right
if you think like there have been a lot
of incidences where Biden has uh touted
EVs and stuff and he never mentions
Tesla yeah well now there's a big there
there was a big shift as of course he's
even promoting and giving tax incentives
to companies that don't produce cars in
the United States Tesla produces cars
exactly all right all right let's let's
talk about Elon from Politico
Elon Musk backs Republicans ahead of
midterms shared power curbs the worst
accesses of both parties musk wrote in a
tweet he wanted to say that he's always
been independent leaning Democrat now
he's saying it's time to vote Republican
to independent-minded voters shared
power curves the worst excesses of both
parties therefore I recommend voting for
a republican Congress given that the
presidency is democratic musk wrote on
Twitter
all right I'll take it I guess he ain't
wrong yeah I mean I think I think that's
the way to go personally and I think a
lot of the states where we have
contentious elections
um you know like New York suddenly it
was very contentious we have Kathy hokel
who is just the worst I mean she's
terrible and we have Lee zeldin who has
the you know broad support of the Jewish
Community that's been facing increasing
anti-Semitism in the city
um and suddenly zeldin has pulled ahead
in the polls that's fascinating I don't
think we've had a republican governor in
New York City New York State uh since uh
Pataki yeah what was the last one that
was like 94. that was uh no 2000 I think
he was also a Bilderberg member uh
George Pataki oh really I had a
conversation with him that didn't go as
as good as I thought already uh but but
the argument that Elon Musk is making
here is essentially I was talking about
this a couple days ago on the show
saying specifically the best government
is no government when the government is
fighting each other that's the
government I want because then the
government isn't fighting you the
citizenry and the points he makes all
your money though well not if they're
not passing laws by by having of course
arguments about them and not agreeing
with them so they're spending less of
your money they're passing less laws
when there's of course a juggernaut
inside of the capital and all of them
are disagreeing on what they should be
doing but what we have going on right
now is we have a Congress that disagrees
with each other that doesn't get
anything done and so then we have a
president who just runs uh executive
orders from the Oval Office spending
trillions of dollars in so doing on all
kinds of random garbage yeah yeah I mean
I mean executive orders have been
normalized by the previous presidents
and it seems like every president is
doing it more and more and more yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean Trump had a bunch
of Executives
Obama had a ton he had more than Bush
and I think we also have to counter and
factor in the Federal Reserve policies
that truly do matter when it comes to
our money but I'm not making the policy
about even just the money I'm talking
about government intervening in your
life and I think that's what Elon Musk
is calling for here at checks of
balances so the Republicans say no to
the Democrats the Democrats say no to
the Republicans I'm all for that yeah I
think what we'll end up seeing if we do
have you know the Red Wave is we're
going to see all of these investigations
because Congress won't be able to get
any laws passed but they will be able to
dig into things and figure out what's
been going on agreed
yeah subpoena power Rand Paul I guess
he's gonna be on like the health
committee or something yeah and Marjory
Taylor Green's going to get some
committees back she wants to be on what
the oversight committee is that what she
said which one did she want to be on but
uh you know she's got McCarthy over a
barrel a little bit and he's gonna have
to put her on whatever she wants and
then maybe a couple years later great
two years later we won't we'll have new
leadership maybe we'll get more America
First candidates in but this is a start
what's the best government Owen give us
the give us the answer here I don't know
I've had so many conflicting opinions of
this as I've gotten older minimal I
think the challenge is with uh I think
any any uh
a lot of these ideologies communism even
anarchism are are utopian they're
idealistic and humans are driven by
emotion one of the challenges with uh
the the marketplace of ideas argument
that we should let all the ideas compete
uh compete with each other which I
mostly agree with is that what we've
seen consistently from the left is
exploitation of emotion for power
and so when you put every idea in the
marketplace and one idea is two plus two
equals four
the left comes in and says you're a
white supremacist and you go huh and
then it makes people feel bad those
feelings drive them more than the facts
do so your argument only works insofar
as you're able to effectively
communicate when you have people who are
clearly not trying to communicate and
trying to deceive and destroy
well you get big problems so we can say
we want to be we want no government we
want to be libertarian we want to say
everybody can do their thing but then
evil people seek to exploit well it goes
even deeper too and you have censorship
so now you can't even fight back
effectively
um I feel like if you have free speech
openly and you can fight back I mean you
can make really really compelling
arguments I mean if there was a platform
where we could speak freely the things
that I the kind of content that I could
make would be off the chains but can't
do it right so that's one part another
thing too is that it's really really
sick and sociopathic when you see some
of the most important issues in the
world things like you know being against
white supremacy then being Twisted for
some kind of political agenda I mean
these are really really important issues
that then get twisted and it actually
devalues it right so if everybody's
being called these things it devalues it
for when there's a real instance of that
which is just one of the sickest things
that I've ever seen and it's one of
these things where then people are
afraid to even give their opinion
um because if you get painted with that
brush it's like it's kind of like
getting becoming radioactive yeah I'm
for Anarchy myself because Anarchy to me
represents decentralization and I think
most of our problems in our society are
plaguing from centralization and I think
the more we break up power the more we
allow individuals to decide for
themselves that is right for them I
think that's the pathway that's going to
help us but then maybe the real answer
is not Anarchy but to recognize that a
system will always the power will always
begin to coalesce and there needs to be
a mechanism to immediately shatter that
centralized power and then recognizing
that your decentralized system will
slowly start to centralize again
I I don't think we have in this country
the proper mechanisms for
re-establishing decentralization and
it's because power doesn't want to give
itself up
so the Constitution has done a really
great job of holding back rapid
centralization but even now the
Constitution is Swiss cheese yeah and
things are really things are really
tightening up at a federal level you
even hear Biden talking about how if the
Democrats hold Congress they're going to
pass um they're going to federally
legalize abortion even though that's not
something that the populace as a whole
wants they're just going to do stuff
anyway and they've been and they I mean
when was the last time they declared war
yeah they don't do that they do Vietnam
they do instead though pass legislation
about not being discriminatory based on
people's hairstyles that's in New York
that's an actual law passed in New York
City yes where if you get caught
discriminating against someone's haircut
allegedly you have to pay what is it a
hundred fifty thousand dollars 125 000.
that's for accidental if it's a willful
uh discrimination it's 250. that's
insane that's too much government that's
too much but I'm pretty sure they put
that in at the federal level I'm pretty
sure that went through Congress I don't
remember hearing I remember hearing it
in New York City specifically yeah it
was definitely in New York City but
they're also going to put in put through
the thing um the federal level where you
basically can't be a freelancer anymore
you know the the like ab5 up in
California
the pro act New York's doing that New
York is doing that but also the federal
government is doing that I think that
what yeah Biden has been pushing for
that for a while that's apocalyptic that
would that so so devastating plan
because it means that people are no
longer in control of their own work
products it means you can't you can't be
an independent you can't just be
yourself and hire yourself out and do
some work so ab5 for those aren't
familiar it was this law they passed in
California that said something like it
was different per job but if you do a
certain number of jobs as an independent
contractor you're now an employee what
happened was instantly my favorite thing
Vox SB Nation fired all their
Freelancers they had to because they
couldn't do it and they couldn't be a
freelancer in California anymore and
also the companies that um the law was
designed to go after like uber and some
other ones got waivers right so they
didn't have to do it but here's here's
the way it works under the this law and
if with the pro Act is that New York or
that Federal the pro act that would be
Federal so this is what that means let's
say you make birdhouses for a living
and then you go to a local shop and say
I'd like to sell you this birdhouse
they'd be I can't buy from you because
if I buy too many then you're an
employee wait what I'm just trying to
sell you a birdhouse well and then they
have all the regulations about different
ways that you have to treat your
employees and you have to give you know
sick leave and parental leave communism
yeah and the other thing too is like
you're just a person you want to work
out of your house you don't want to be
beholden to some company you don't want
them to tell you what to do and the next
thing you know you can't you know make
yourself I'm an employer based out of
California and I can tell you that once
they started bringing that stuff in we
actually decided just to shrink and then
when covet happened we decided to shrink
even more and we actually became a lot
more efficient and profitable I was the
kind of person where I just we usually
have around 100 employees and I did that
because I just like to hire people I
just want people to get paid and I like
making jobs but when they start messing
with you like that you're like you know
what forget it we're just going to
become more efficient and that's what we
did and now there's homeless people
everywhere because they're struggling to
function in the society yeah well vote
for more of it I guess tomorrow hey
here's your chance if you want to Bright
it all down yeah but I'm not even
kidding many any of these far leftists
are like if you vote for them they will
keep burning it down I actually hit a
point where um because I run a seminars
company and they wouldn't let us do
seminars anymore during covid and I
decided just to travel around and just
hang out in the outdoors I skied every
major ski resort I went to almost every
National Park I just drove the country I
said I'm good I don't need to run some
big company
um we can run it more profitably without
all that stuff we just liked making jobs
but if they're saying that they're going
to mess with us like that what's the
incentive like how do I know they're not
going to lock down again I don't know
that so I don't care if they're going to
play those games like Atlas shark you
ever read Atlas yeah I'm just like I'm
chill it's all good you gotta leave
California yeah I mean I am and they're
demoral I want to move to Wyoming
actually I want to ski but they're
demoralizing employers yeah it sucks
it's been horrible out there why why are
you still there yeah they're doing that
across La is pretty awesome it actually
is pretty awesome but not really it's
super duper awesome
come visit sometime I invite you guys I
live there you guys got to come crash
it's a lot of fun but I've lived there
for a couple years it's not awesome you
know well you got to live in the right
place where'd you live I lived in
Koreatown I lived in Westwood and I
lived in North Hollywood okay well I
hope you'll come visit sometime I want
to show you around but okay just come
you live in the right places it burns
out yeah apparently had the wrong
experience yeah but the point the point
being is that Caruso might get in we're
all hoping for Rick Caruso we're all
praying you're still gonna have Newsom
and he's a menace we just got to pray
for Caruso all right all right well
check it out check it out maybe maybe
from the daily wire Superstar Katy Perry
confirms she's voting for Rick Caruso
this is a guy he's technically a
Democrat but he was a republican until
he decided like a couple weeks before he
decided to be uh is that what happened I
think he was a republican then he's like
I'm gonna run Democrat switched parties
then ran and now you got this big old
picture of Katy Perry voting for a what
is effectively a republican so what does
that mean does that mean there's there's
hope she's got G is it Jesus tattooed on
her wrist um I mean I'd be willing to
bet that she's probably votes Republican
in secret anyway
she might the other thing with Rick
Caruso is that he owns The Grove Mall
which is the best mall in LA and it's
super duper clean
um I think so so it's probably awesome
yeah we should probably fact check that
but I think he does so the thing is is
that the Optics of this perfectly clean
like the most clean part of LA and then
kind of juxtaposing that against the
rest of La that's getting a little bit
overrun it's uh just the Optics of it
just feels good let's just make sure
that I got that correct Caruso
Affiliated owns The Grove and the Grove
is so beautiful and everybody in la lo
loves it so it's like this beautiful
clean place so just seeing that is the
perfect optics for somebody who I don't
think there's anything that everyone in
New York City loves we have a Central
Park it's yeah Central Park I lived in
New York City I grew up in New York City
I think everyone loves Central Park
probably that might be the only thing
but the Grove is so clean so this is
perfect it's clean it's orderly
everybody loves the Grove but now the
cops arrest you and give you tickets if
you're there past like 11 p.m or 12 p.m
in New York City Central Park which is
absolutely Draconian and we're back to
the thing where you're where if you're a
woman walk talking by yourself you're
not walking through the park after dark
like we are back to that I was talking
to a friend of mine the other night and
she's like I don't walk through McCarran
Park after dark anymore well there was
that there used to be no issue at all
that young woman at uh worship Columbia
yeah she got murdered by those like
teenagers or whatever yeah and she's not
the only one I mean teenagers are out
there killing people there was a young
man on the subway 14 years old who was
murdered by a gang of girls stealing his
iPhone
14. wow they murder him they stabbed him
to death and he didn't know them the
they were not at all connected yeah in
New York City when you need help from
the cops they're not there and many
times there's somebody else
when you when you are by Trump Tower and
you want to complain about black lives
man on the street the police are there
to arrest you yeah of course yes I was
finishing my statement there in
particular also talking about how if
there's a ticket to be written they're
there they're gonna do it but if you
need help I know multiple instances
where people were getting shot stabbed
or beaten and the cops were literally
standing by and watching not doing
these violent criminals who are
committing these crimes are are let out
of jail because it's only fair right I
mean you know a cash bail is is holding
someone unreasonably right
yeah there's again there's a guy named
there's a guy named Matt bellinson I
want an answer to this this statement
but if you have someone committing
crimes in New York should we extend to
them our principles of letting them out
of jail instead of or should we hold
them that's not the same Market I don't
have that principle of letting people
out of jail so so so we locked up if
they commit crimes but you got to prove
it right you can't just arrest someone
without proving it before a jury of
their peers okay but so that's you know
do you believe that people should be
should only be imprisoned if they're
proven guilty Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
uh probably not I think probably you
should be able to sit in jail waiting
for your trial if you're a violent
person so not anything committed a
violent crime so so the idea is the
government shouldn't be allowed to put
you in jail
unless they've proven you've committed a
crime but what we've done this side is
we've recognized there's actually like a
a gradient here it's not absolute and
that is some people are so dangerous we
actually decide even before we've proven
it we're going to remand them and not
release them now that's a challenge I
have an issue with that because my
values are you the government should not
be able to put you in a box and lock it
up unless they've proven Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt you've actually done
something wrong because innocent people
do suffer because of this however I also
recognize letting the letting people out
in this regard results in rampant
violent crime and I don't know what the
solution is but I can tell you cashless
bail has only made things worse yeah
they were supposed to do cashless bail
only for non-violent offenders and it
hasn't really worked out that way
because people will be led out of jail
and two days later they're back in
because they've killed somebody they've
seen this happen in Chicago and New York
and all over the place and that means
the solution is people get put in jail
for extended periods of time because the
system can't handle it even if they're
they're not proven guilty that's a
that's a problem that is a problem and
the court system should work a lot
faster like you shouldn't be sitting
there having a trial two years after you
did the thing or like you know just
stuck in jail I get that time but that's
like there was a story I saw where a
Starbucks had huge lines going to drive
through into the street so the city
voted to ask Starbucks Starbucks workers
to work faster oh nice like if we don't
have if if the city is so Rife with
crime and so dense that the court
systems and the police can't actually
properly adjudicate crimes actually have
bail hearings then the whole system is
just totally screwed up and busting
there's I don't even know how you fix it
so the problem we have now is our values
and this is what the progressives have
been advocating for in cities like like
La New York and Chicago and whatever is
you should not be able to imprison
someone for any any reason I mean that
in the locals it's not the legal sense
unless you've proven it and that that
includes a bail hearing but because
there's so much crime you have people
lined up and the judge is like I don't
have time for this
remand you're violent or a person's like
your honor I argue he's not violent okay
fine you can leave no no cash bail then
they go murder people again
I think the problem is there is no like
we can be as principled as we want to be
we have a very serious problem we do
have a serious problem and we have crime
Rising even though we have Democrats
telling us that it's just that that's
just I'm mostly in big cities these days
and um I was at Surfside tacos last
night here in DC or just close to here
and uh we got shot at actually last
night I'm not even kidding
everybody's hitting the ground last
night getting a taco I'm like well I'm
gonna go out get a taco what am I kid's
gonna pick no big deal we all laughed it
off but it happened
um Mom my kids had to stop a robbery
recently in Los Angeles had to get in a
fist fight the mother of my kids my
buddy Sid got pistol whipped in New York
and romford's watch right by piano bar
uh yeah I know right then he got clocked
by another crazy guy uh in weho in Los
Angeles
um you walk down the street in LA and it
there is a huge homeless encampments of
tents that just run all down Sunset
Boulevard I mean it's getting crazy you
can't walk down the street I don't know
what you're talking about like you can't
walk down the street like the all the
imperments literally really block you
from walking down the side yeah you have
to actually walk on to yeah what he's
saying you have to walk onto Sunset
Boulevard yeah and then you walk by the
encampments Yeah and um they're not look
they're nice they haven't caused any
problems but what if I'm with my kids
I'm not gonna walk by that like if I'm
if I'm walking around the city I you
know and I see like a bunch of homeless
junkies like nodding off I cross the
street I'm not gonna walk by that I'm
not gonna do it I'm not walking by with
my kid and I'm not walking by by myself
like totally you know the risk reward
scenario is just it's just not there
what do we do about this what do we do
we start arresting the open-air drive
markets you know we used to do that
right so when Giuliani came into office
in New York City and like what 93 or
something like that he started cleaning
up City by doing exactly that he was
just started arresting people arresting
people for selling drugs and it was you
know it was pretty severe and I remember
at the time being like what is this but
um the city turned into a paradise
within about 15 years and it was
spectacular to live there yeah that
sounds very effective I get I it sounds
authoritarian it does sound
authoritarian but I mean I think when
you're talking about a big city when
you're talking about millions of people
living on top of one another who need to
have a safe place to walk and you know
Safe Streets safe Parks safe places to
walk around and to do their business and
all of that and this is my argument but
at this point too we have a much
different situation because we're
completely decriminalized marijuana and
this is right so this is my argument
when it comes to people like Ethan and
Kathy Griffin when they're actively
advocating against our rights to free
speech I say they're banned okay good
riddance like if if someone is innocent
in New York City and they get arrested I
hope they are not held and that's why I
don't like the idea of cash bail that a
poor person who's in the wrong place at
the wrong time gets arrested and the
state is just like too bad for you
that's screwed up yeah but now we see
what happens when you have cashless bail
people are being pushed in front of
subway trains people yeah people are
being slashed so I don't know security
versus freedom I lean towards second
Amendment the issue however is you want
to err on the side of stop violence
meaning more innocent people get locked
up or on the side of protecting the
innocent meaning more bad people go free
we tend to air on the side of bad people
going free but in a certain situation
now too at a certain point we just say
if we know the person is violent and
actively sowing like violence
destruction we remand them if you've got
people like you know these these
prominent leftists who are going to
Advocate against speech and cheer for
censorship we say remind them when they
get sponsored I'm not letting them out
that can be adjudicated somewhere else
yeah I mean we have a system that
incentivizes crime uh incentivizes some
of the worst behaviors while making
citizens uh defenseless that's a major
problem that that of course we need to
talk about more because people were able
to defend themselves if people weren't
being prosecuted by George Soros
district attorneys that punish people
for self-defense it would be a totally
different landscape if politicians and
the school system and the education
system weren't incentivizing a lot of
this violent nonsense I don't think we
would be in in this kind of system so I
I think the problem is very complex I
think it can't just be solved in one
simple conversation or in one simple
phrase but at the end of the day I think
the government's making it a lot worse
than that I have I have and more
government wouldn't make it better in my
opinion I have an analogy that I used uh
for Ian you know Ian really loves us
he's in a science
I was imagining living in New York City
and I uh I was imagining when I did live
there I lived on Myrtle and Nostrand in
this apartment building in a small like
700 square foot box with people to my
top left right and behind me and below
me and then I was just like man I can't
play music here you can't you get you
can get an acoustic guitar and you can
play during certain hours you can't play
drums right you can get practice pads or
maybe an electric kit and then put you
know headphones on or something but you
can't be noisy and I started to think
was as people get pushed closer you you
have this as an individual you have this
bubble of freedoms around you as you get
further and further away from other
people that bubble grows and grows and
grows where you're no you're not
impeding on anybody else's life As you
move closer and closer to people the
bubble starts getting pressed upon by
other people's bubbles so I I you know
Ian loved as I said it was like rural
people are basically like geshists
bouncing around all crazy having all
this Freedom having a good time and then
as you move closer and closer to the
city becomes more solid where you
literally can't do anything you can't be
noisy you can't be up too late you can't
blast the stereo you can't have your
guns can't have your guns can't can't
cook stinky Foods because there's too
many people around you you are
solidified in this block that's rigid
and controlled and I think the problem
is there is no ideological or policy
solution to population density there's
none you recognize that if you live in a
big city there's going to be too much
crime because there's too many people
and the police and the courts won't be
able to handle it properly properly so I
just I think it's fair to say there's no
simple solution
but there's been an incentivized program
within the last few decades pushing
people to live in cities wanting people
to live on top of each other yes I think
that kind of lifestyle lifestyle has
been glorified I think there's been a
lot of manipulation to make it seem like
it's trendy like it's cool like a tip
when in reality it's an absolute
hellscape where police officers try to
steal your money to generate revenue for
the state while of course making sure
you're defenseless as the crackhead who
stabs you uh you know as they're
literally sitting there watching you uh
that's life in New York City but that's
life like that before it wasn't like
well it wasn't like that in the 90s
because I grew up in New York City in
the 90s
it was and then it got changed and got
better it got more authoritarian broken
windows policing yes and crime dropped
dramatically did it or was it just a
reporting because we also have to
understand here the New York City Police
Department manipulates manipulates the
reporter
yes of course but but I'm saying crime
goes in waves but when there's a program
and and there's been an epidemic of New
York City police officers that have been
downgrading particular crimes to make it
seem like it's not a big issue whether
it's you know uh you know assault it was
simple batteries whether it's robberies
it was just a small petty theft and a
lot of the times police officers got
caught lessening the crimes in order to
make their Precinct look like it was
good and tough on crime when in reality
there was a lot of crime and what
essentially Giuliani did he violated a
lot of people's civil rights but he also
contained the crime in particular areas
uh and essentially pushed it away and it
still continued but only continued in
certain neighborhoods yes that's exactly
right they turned Manhattan into a
glorious playground for The Super Rich
yes yes and for those of us who wandered
about in it yes let's uh let's talk
about tomorrow
we have the story from space.com
what is a Blood Moon published three
days ago
my friends
at 302 a.m Eastern Time
the blood moon will begin for those of
you on the west coast it will be at 1202
A.M
it's fascinating when I first heard that
a blood red moon would be happening on a
full moon on the day of the midterm
elections signifying a great red Beacon
I was like wow that's that's the
literally the definition of ominous but
then I thought 3 AM though what does
that mean 3 A.M that's that's not that's
not ominous at all and then I realized
oh Pacific time that means when the sun
when when the when the day starts for
the contiguous United States and
everyone is now
in November 8th the day of the midterms
the moon will turn blood red and it was
funny too because I don't know if it was
you Luke who mentioned this it's not a
blue moon yeah and there is a Blue Moon
yes it's a second full moon in the month
and we're not having that we're having a
blood moon
so the blood moon is coming and this
one's for all of you my friends because
people are referring to it as the Maga
Moon
I Google searched the spiritual meaning
of the blood moon and I would like to
read for you the opening sentence
the ancient Incans and Mesopotamians
believed the blood moon was an omen
portending death and overthrow of the
king how about that you know what is up
that's crazy and this is going to be
happening in a few hours yeah and this
is this is also the same day that a lot
of people on social media are saying
that Donald Trump will announce that
he's going to be running for president
in 2024 I'm watching his speech right
now in Dayton Ohio and there's also news
that the entire Trump family is going to
be in attendance for this news
watching I'm watching the speech now and
I'm on a monitoring social media but but
there's a lot of symbolism here and I
think it's fair to say that there's
going to be a lot of crazy things uh in
our social political discourse that uh
are going to be very eye-opening in the
next few hours so definitely pay
attention to what's going on here I know
I'm closely paying attention to all the
details as they're unfolding here
everyone's on their cell phones now
seeing what's going on on social media
but I'm keeping an eye on it
the crew at the post millennial who are
totally
we just gotta wait as soon as we get
word if Trump announces because he's not
going to be speaking for I told them to
message me I'm keeping an eye on the
rally over I don't know but he's talking
forever yeah
but let's let's let me ask you guys
when you see stuff like a blood moon a
red moon right when the day starts
on the midterms when people calling for
a red wave and The Omen is that a blood
mood signifies the the overthrow of the
king
how do you guys feel about that I think
it's fun it's a lot of fun you know I
don't know if I believe in
uh all of the things having some sort of
I say when you see super universe is it
also a full moon or whatever yes so
that's going to be another major issue
because you know I I I have a lot of
friends and family that work in
emergency services and they tell me
every time it's a full moon we know it's
going to want to be a full work day we
know there's going to be a lot of people
losing their ish
um so that there is you know there's
there's a lot of ingredients you
verified is that true well that's what
my friends and family told it's true
I've heard this as well yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I have but I have some family
members that are nurses some that are
police officers and they tell me like
like full moon it gets crazy it's a
simple explanation it's very bright
during a full moon yeah yeah you can go
around and do stuff that's right uh
during a new Moon I mean everybody who
lives outside of a city knows this you
don't need to but the crazy thing is
people in cities really don't get it
there's that famous story where the
power went out in LA in the 90s and
everyone started calling 9-1-1 because
there was a strange thing in the sky it
was the Milky Way they'd seen for the
first time in their lives it's crazy but
for a lot of people who live outside of
a city you know like there's Moonshadow
people in cities just it's permanent
illumination they don't even realize the
shadow yeah yeah and also you know my
friends and family reported a lot of
people just going crazy losing their
mind a lot of mental health calls a lot
of people just going absolutely berserk
and crazy so that with the the elections
with possibly Trump announcing with this
blood red moon uh with turbulence wait
wait someone super chatted uh uh a
raftus of stat said that 3am is the
witching hour
what are the statistical chances that a
Blood Moon could be on the same night as
this how often does the Blood Moon
happen it's five years yeah yeah it's
every five years
are you guys uh atheists you believe in
god what do you believe in I believe in
God I'm not I don't believe in organ any
organized religion though but it's it's
things like this I'll say
this in and of itself is not enough to
convince me of a great power beyond or
anything like that because coincidences
happen I mean people win the lottery
but what are the chances of something
like I look blood moons happen elections
happen I would love to see someone break
down the probability of the blood moon
happening at 1202 a.m Pacific
on the day of an election like we know
when our elections are going to be
they're all pre-planned it's like the
first Tuesday or whatever you know of
the month of November and then we know
when full moons are going to be because
we can track mathematically very simply
what's the probability of that occurring
you know is it going to be like one
every 17 000 years when every three
years what are five years with the blood
moon what it's certainly not because it
would happen every single time but what
if it's like really common what if it's
like actually you know every third or
fourth blood Moon's probably going to
fall on a November or Tuesday or
whatever I kind of feel like it's
extremely rare maybe somebody knows the
math I don't know I see stuff like that
not the math it's things like this that
you see enough of and eventually they're
just like there's too many weird things
like that that happen to just believe
we're in some random catech Universe
there's there's a there's some kind of
structure to all of this I I 100 think
it means something 100 what all the
stuff all the stuff combined means
something I do
blood moon there's a lot of really
really bad stuff happening in the past
couple years as you guys are aware of
but there's always a lot of really bad
stuff happening the last two years
there's always a lot of really it just
depends on where you're standing and
what you're looking at that I agree with
but what's been happening here is next
level yeah Ukraine pretty bad but it's
always I mean you guys I mean the thing
is it's kind of always like this I wish
we could dig deeper this is what
humanity is like we're constantly facing
I think the sad thing existential crisis
we can't even dig too deep into some of
the things going on but it's just sad I
mean there's crazy stuff happening sure
but there's all I mean there's literally
always crazy stuff the thing is always
having technology is something so
quickly that's always happening yeah but
we're I'm just trying to evaluate what
we can get into this whole thing of like
weird and inflection point in history
that Biden is always talking about like
I think it's always this nuts when I
talk to you know my grandparents have
passed but they used to talk about all
kinds of crazy things happening like
they had World War II they had the
Holocaust for goodness sakes they had
the Great Depression my grandfather was
like mucking around in the woods of
Billerica Massachusetts to forage from
mushrooms to feed his family and by the
time he was an older man like if he
looked at a mushroom he would Wretch
like stuff is always nuts let me read
this let me read this in the Western
Christian tradition the hour between 3
A.M and 4 a.m was considered a period of
peak Supernatural activity this time is
also referred to as the devil's hour due
to it being a mocking inversion of time
in which Jesus supposedly died which was
3 pm right that's like the whole reverse
like everything in scripture it's
reversed in order to make it uh satanic
you have like the black mass that
happens you know in the middle of the
night and all of this stuff but also in
um you know in ye olden times that's
when people would wake up because they
would go to bed after it got dark and
then they would kind of wake up in the
middle of the night correct and do stuff
and then go back to bed what does the
omen portend will it does it mean that
at some point in the next three years I
saw so it's not I don't think it's once
every five years I think that's on
average I'm not sure I was reading a
couple articles but I think uh yeah the
blood moon the blood moon might be once
every five but there's going to be
another total lunar eclipse three years
later
so we have this blood moon in the way
this three year period maybe it's
meaningless I don't know all I can think
is that song you remember that song
Total Eclipse of the Heart yep that's
all I can think of right now it's
running through my head so I think it's
a lot of fun I don't know that I put a
lot of stock in all of the various you
know poor tents or whatever like that
but I do think that it makes it a little
bit extra exciting to think about
so here's what here's what let's let's
just we'll get some science here they
say a Blood Moon that happens when
Earth's moon is in a total lunar eclipse
while it while it has no special
astronomical significance the view in
the sky is striking as the usually
whitish Moon becomes red or Ruddy Brown
lunar eclipses can only happen during a
full moon when the sun fully illuminates
the surface usually a full moon has no
Eclipse because the moon orbits in a
slightly different plane than the Earth
and the Sun however at times the planes
coincide Earth passes in between the
Moon and the Sun and cuts off sunlight
causing an eclipse so what is a what
makes it red
during a full eclipse the Moon is an
Earth's Shadow blah blah blah a red moon
appears can depend on how much pollution
is that what it is
is it just pollution blood moon calendar
okay here we go so there was actually
another one this year 16th of May
anything happen on May 16th
I don't recall November 8th the next
will be March uh 14 2025.
and then September 7th 2025 and then
March 3rd 2026.
oh no I'm checking my date book
just just the one day it lines up huh so
that's the thing like what's the
likelihood of this Blood mood lining up
on election day and a time when people
are calling for a red wave and expecting
Republicans to win and
Well it can't be uh it says in the
bottom right there it can't be anything
but pollution because curse for Columbus
use it apparently back in the day yeah
so I guess there's like pollution makes
it look more red uh okay I understand
yeah I don't know I don't remember
anything on those dates at all
May 16th I came on the I was I was on
your show two days later oh man that's
real bad news right I mean you're you're
going to be doing all the chaos right it
was all my fault
so we have this video basically
explaining it Los Angeles
before the moon sets
we actually uh where we are it looks
like the moon's gonna go in an arc over
the mountains so we'll be able to like
track it we're gonna try and film it see
if we can get it it's crazy I remember
you know sometimes I just I I remember
seeing several Blood Moons throughout my
life and just not even realizing it was
like what it was or what was going on
it's like oh blood moon I didn't realize
that was today just look with the moon
and it's terrifying yeah pretty scary
so what do you think I was getting
overthrown yeah I mean
I I I hope the people in charge uh but
only time will tell that being in charge
they're terrible at it well I don't know
yeah I think I think it all depends on
perspective some would say what they're
doing is absolute genius because they
kind of make excuses and they make make
it look like uh an old man who's who's
not really well is really in charge of
everything when in reality I don't think
that's the case at all but I was gonna
throw it at you Owen because you were
talking about uh you know do you believe
in god what about you what do you
believe in I do and the thing is that as
you're on your journey I think that
you'll see these things that'll come up
in your field of experience that are
like one in millions and you'll see this
again and again and again as you keep
down that path you'll see this
repeatedly and you'll question it
because you're like this is impossible
how could this be and I've just seen too
much of this as I've gotten older it
just it's it's uh I don't even like
talking about it I feel like it cheapens
it it's just one of those things that
you'll experience like even when you
were saying um
like there I almost don't even want to
pipe in because I feel like
there's just certain things that happen
that cheapens it if you go too deep into
it but there's just certain coincidences
that are so intense and so crazy as you
move on and um I think this is one of
them you know I I think things are
happening now personally so we'll see
let's let's look back in a couple years
I think that human beings have a
propensity to feel like they are at the
Pinnacle of history and are at the end
of human existence I thought you made a
great point about the Holocaust and all
these other terrible things happen I
thought you had a great point there yeah
I did I I can make more of them too we
like to find patterns and things yeah
yeah part of what we do
yeah but then some of these things as
you're on your journey will be these one
in a million coincidences that let you
do things that are so unbelievable and
so it's one of these things where
um you'll become more like I would
encourage you just to even continue to
look for these things I think that
you're on a great journey I think you'll
see them if you look all right man
thanks sounds like a real serious but uh
just keep robbing
how many of you bought Powerball tickets
I meant to but I didn't realize I had to
do it 2.9 billion yeah 11 pm is when
they're doing the drawing
my friend asked me to get one and I I
didn't didn't someone say that that the
lottery is pretty much a tax on the poor
yeah it is basically and like the money
goes to the state uh we were talking
about this yesterday I'm like you know
if I win the lottery how much of that
money actually goes to me how much of it
goes to the state how would I feel
knowing that I'm giving so much of that
money to the state I'd feel horrible
there's another joke how come
uh how come college students never win
the lottery why they're too smart to
play
the reason why you always hear these
stories of old people winning the
lottery it's because they play all the
time and young people are like I'm
buying a lottery ticket I have never
bought a lottery ticket it's a status
Ponzi scheme gambling that takes away
your money like the reason I've never
bought a lottery ticket is that I have
been concerned I would get obsessed and
then always buy a lottery ticket think
about this 1.9 billion dollars the cash
payout is 929 million yeah no I was like
I'm gonna buy one today here's here's
the thing like I had been talked into it
people's lives get destroyed by the
lottery yeah because they don't
understand what happens when you have
money for like for people who've grown
up around it or earned their way into it
slowly you see this like imagine this
I'll tell you guys when you start
becoming when you start becoming more
successful people around you become evil
as evil can possibly be and you're and
you learn who your true friends really
are and then you also learn you know
who's like never really a friend but
they really want free stuff but it is it
is is unsurprising I mean
I I should say it was surprising to me
to discover how many people that you
think are your friends try not to be
just extremely evil yeah but imagine one
day you don't just earn your way into it
and experience it slowly over time we're
like I can't believe someone would do
this to me this is crazy and then after
five years of you you know continually
being wealthy and successful you're like
I get it I gotta be on guard and hire
lawyers and have police have security
guards imagine one day you're working
class and next thing you're worth 900
million dollars knives out all the evil
people instantly at once draw their
blades for you it's it's it's
I just want to make a really really
quick Point here I dated a girl who won
the lottery and she was like I wish I
never won it because it ripped her
family apart and a lot of people who win
the lottery uh they're miserable because
of it and they lose the money very
quickly as well so what did you win like
millions or something uh yeah tens of
millions yeah Aaron Carter the younger
brother of Nick Carter from the
Backstreet Boys just died and you'll see
a lot of this and I mean again coming
from La you see a lot of people that
come into Fame quickly and there's two
different types of people they come into
Fame it's you know someone like you know
pretty much you guys at this table where
you've had to kind of earn your way up
and it's kind of a grind but some people
sort of get plucked up by The
Establishment and they get put into a
Fame you know base and they do have
talent I'm not trying to say that it's
binary they do have talent but they get
plucked up so quickly and put into Fame
so quickly well he was nine when he did
his first video that's what I'm saying
right and so what can happen is that um
uh they get hooked on drugs they get too
many fake friends around them they get
they get ungrounded and in personal
growth and self-help the biggest thing
they talk about all the time is that if
you win the lottery it just destroys
your life you have to actually have the
psyche of somebody who's wealthy to be
able to maintain it I'm 100 sure I could
handle it you guys want it for something
someone just super chatted this to me
Jay wood shout out Trump was born during
a blood moon June 14th
check it out here it is on Wikipedia
1946 check it out born Donald J Trump
June 14th 1946. I looked it up wow June
14th 1946 lunar eclipse right there and
there it is the blood moon that could be
why he couldn't today that could be why
he could be announcing today he's gonna
announce at 3am he's gonna talk non-stop
that 300 like did the moon change yet
I'm running everybody he's still talking
right now I'm watching him talk right
now anyway anyway back to the lottery
stuff's interesting so uh well it's also
a psyche of being at the effect right
it's like these shows like uh these
shows that pluck up the average person
and make them famous or things like that
or reality TV or taking people that
aren't that talented and making them
famous it's more of this idea that the
establishment like that you're at the
effect of life then the big
establishment which is kind of like this
sort of like pimple relationship they
come up they pluck you up and then they
make you famous the way to get Success
is Not By grinding it out it's by just
being this like perfectly compliant
person then they'll just pluck you up
and make you famous if Harvey
Weinstein's happy with you you're going
to get the role yeah exactly right right
if Les Wexner is happy with you you're
gonna get that modeling gig at
Victoria's Secret you know if Mr Epstein
or Mr Clinton are happy with you you
might get that good political job it's
also why a lot of bad governments get
elected because people are in that kind
of psychology so one of the biggest
things to actually changing kind of
governments get elected is teaching
people to think for themselves I think
that's actually the battle of the coming
century is teaching people to think for
themselves teaching them not to use
groupthink as a easy out to thinking and
when you take someone especially like a
child and you make up like a Disney star
you see horrible ramifications when you
do that when you just throw them into
Fame and these parents that just give
their child to these den of vipers in
Hollywood seriously I mean when you look
at Hollywood there's a lot of you know
we're talking about spiritual stuff
there's a lot of satanic evil devilish
elements inside of Hollywood and and in
Washington DC where of course the
biggest amount of psychopaths kind of
coalesce and then they prey on the
innocent they take people and then they
bring them into and they give them all
this money and all this Fame they can't
handle it and then they they prey on
their weaknesses and their mistakes and
that's the entire establishment industry
that we're dealing with right now there
are a lot of parents though who
intentionally exploit their children for
you know various financial gain and
that's yeah that's crazy yeah it's crazy
but they do it not just in Hollywood
they do it all over yeah like Dwayne
Wade you know yeah like Dwayne Wright
yeah like the is being accused of being
accused with his model child right his
yeah I think he's also just very bought
into a certain narrative Dwayne Wade
seems like a very Gabriel Union helped
yeah like Dwayne Wade looks like an
exceedingly positive person but I think
he's very bought into a certain
narrative I think so too I also um
I've recently been like I think there's
an issue with stepmothers I know there's
some good stepmothers but I think that I
think it's
crazy I've been thinking about that
myself the crazy thing I would tell
people about stuff like Lottery wins it
used to be that uh people would lose the
money really really fast they would
waste it on insane things and their
lives would be destroyed by it
recently because of documentaries
talking about this people have instantly
started going to financial advisors and
then getting things set up in order but
the one thing you can't
advise away from is Humanity that it's
not even about you you can't like I'll
tell you man if you won 929 million
dollars
that that actually sounds nightmarish
you're going to have people trying to
kill you you're not gonna so like we we
get this all the time with uh death
threats swattings bomb threats it's just
it's nuts imagine not having any
experience with it not having dealt with
this level of of insanity and all of a
sudden one day overnight it's like oh
someone's gonna try and kill you
actually tons of people are gonna try
and kill you they know where you live
they announced you won good luck or they
just become infatuated by you and then
want to love you and become so centered
on you that they make you the focus of
their life and then they become
destructive in that way uh but one of
the smartest things that I saw was an
announcement for someone who won the
lottery and he decided to wear the
scream mask and he's literally getting
the check because some lotteries make
you uh have the photo make you of course
sign a lot of documents do a lot of PR
do a lot of news interviews he says I'm
not doing any of that I'm putting on a
mask he was photographed with the mask
and it's one of the smartest things that
that I've ever seen Anonymous he's like
I don't want I don't want family members
bothering me yeah I'll help my family
happiness about a certain amount of
money it's really about having a
beautiful ecosystem purpose in life and
you know great friends and stuff and so
if you're in an ecosystem of people that
aren't used to that kind of wealth and
that's who you're surrounded by
um there's this thing we called an Ras
flip so it's reticular activation system
it actually explains why people on the
left or the right see the world
differently it's called Ras particular
activation system it's selective focus
we see the world very very differently
we don't believe what we see we see what
we believe and so we have very very
selective focus so if Tim you mentioned
that you had a lot of people turn evil
on you as you got success I had a
similar experience it's actually
heartbreaking and it's confusing as hell
if you've never experienced it and so
what happens is that like they don't ask
for anything there's instantly become
evil it's crazy it's terrifying and some
of your best friends and and it's not
even that they've hurt you it's that
real friends stab you in the back and
it's dehumanizing and it's not about
politics like obviously for political
races people are out today but in my
experience it's like for literally no
reason maybe it's jealousy yeah it's it
so what it is called an res flip so
basically as your value changes what
they see in you changes so reticular
activation system just look this up I
would advise anybody to look this up and
selective focus once you get this you
see why people see the world differently
we have very very selective folks we
don't believe what we see we see what we
believe and what it's like if you have a
breakup with a significant other and
then firstly idealize you because
they're getting something from you later
in a breakup they like say that there
was a hundred experiences let's just to
be round number right 98 of them are
positive two or negative well then when
they like you they focus on the 98
positive then if you break up and it
hurts then they focus more on the two
negative ones RS flip a year later you
forget the bad things start to remember
all the good things and then wonder why
you broke up 100 and so and and that's
why it's it's human to do that but
you're getting that same effect as
you've gained success that's why you've
seen that people are having res flips
they're seeing things differently once
you study this and you basically just
understand res it clarifies a ton of
Select what about have you seen anything
on that absolutely like time and time
again we were just talking about this
yesterday uh and and it's it's real a
lot of people have this kind of Illusion
a lot of people are hypnotized that that
money and fame are something that is
everything in life when in reality it's
it's usually a burden more than it is a
gift to anything else and unless you
grow into it yeah yeah but essentially
when people just focus just on that and
not the journey and not their life and
and not the experiences and not the
loved ones that they have around them
and they just focus I want money I want
money I want fame I want fame they
destroy everything in their pathway and
when they do get it they're they're more
miserable than anyone else yeah the
bhagavad-gita which is a major Eastern
text talks about the process of being
everything or you know Eckhart Tolle
Power of Now it's about being present
being in the now the process itself the
Bible they talk about the same thing uh
doubtaging they talk about the same
thing that you know the beauty of life
is in the present moment the unfolding
of the journey the energy and money is a
great thing too but it's just one
component yes absolutely but you put all
a secret if you win if you win that 1.9
billion that's all I can say is just
whatever don't tell anybody about it
yeah don't tell anybody but you know
what the problem is
that people are inexperienced this stuff
so they want to tell people they don't
get it they don't understand and they
don't have the money manager so the
government and the state takes what 52
percent of all of it you know do what
Bill Gates does get a non-profit get an
organization that you run donate all the
money there and then you can do whatever
you want with the money no it's sort of
well you could double your wealth just
like Bill Gates into MC Hammer remember
MC Hammer Mike Tyson Mike Tyson lost all
of his money a lot of uh hammer games
one of my staff who got very wealthy
very quickly he actually blows money he
called it he used to call it hammer time
but he got to blow all his money he
called hammer time he'd say I MC
hammered all my money he MC hammered
about a million dollars wow wow he's
made it back but yeah he had a fun year
it's crazy man it really is nuts and
it's not it's not it's not about money
you know it's just like if crabs in a
bucket maybe jealousy I don't know it's
the res flip it's your value changes and
then it tweaks their perception again
um it's this is a really deep topic but
it okay simple version would be
um it kind of hijacks the part of the
brain that's very in the physical and so
you want to think of it like mind body
and soul right and so it gets them kind
of into their body the body is
inherently kind of sociopathic if you
look at like a nature documentary the
animals are killing each other eating
each other look at the ocean the fish
are eating each other so people can kind
of go into that mode and it's
unfortunate because politicians actually
manipulate this right if you can keep
everybody in that kind of primitive mode
then you can get them voting in bad
policies this is why critical thinking
and personal growth is going to be the
major battle the next hundred years I
think so weird though like why don't
they feel that way about Obama
uh because he's placating them but but
how I mean like look my point is this
when I say that people turn evil it's
like without Rhyme or Reason people in
my life what's an example uh just I'll
try to give a light example of some guy
I've known since I was a teenager we
used to hang out all the time skate
together we we were roommates briefly uh
just as just instantly started
smack talking me on online lying about
everything going to people and trying to
I don't know I think that may have been
like hey they thought maybe they could
get famous or something by claiming so
what it is is that in in personal growth
we would say that we live in the same
physical reality but we live in parallel
energetic realities and so what's
happened is you've entered into a
different energetic reality and they're
just living in a different reality it's
like if you took somebody homeless and
you bring them into a mansion they're PR
they might still be doing drugs in the
bathroom right they're not just gonna be
looking at the view so what happened is
you created a disconnect with them even
if you work with people and then you
keep elevating and they're not you'll
see there's there's a natural split it
just can't hold together
my point is like why doesn't a person
hold the negative view of other high
status people especially High status
people who are like deeply involved in
controversial things because because
you're close to them right but it's
almost like what amount of money would
have to be on this table before you'd
get uncomfortable would it be like if
there's a billion of if there was a you
might not because you're a principled
person but if there was a billion
dollars sitting right there would you
start getting any adrenaline or no no
okay well there's a point where
everybody okay well it's just money what
would be so much of value to you that if
it was sitting right there you'd start
to be like whoa nothing I don't
understand so you're a very very
principal person well there's a point
where people just go crazy right so it's
like like what's people's breaking point
where they'll break their principles so
one hobby that I have I run seminars is
um usually they try to kick me out about
midnight and so I'll go to the person
that wants to shut down the room and
I'll say
um could I say a bit longer they're like
no no I can't I say what about if I give
you 20 bucks and they're like no no I
can't and then I say what if I give you
500 bucks and then they're like oh of
course you know just say you're so they
crack the average person's principles
cracks Under Pressure but the reason why
you've been independently successful is
you have strong principles so they may
not have had that opportunity or focused
on personal Evolution they've probably
never had that discussion about
themselves in the first that's amazing
that you've done that it's amazing
you've done that but the average person
the average person is not doing that
they're not taught to they're taught to
look at Tick Tock I think it's I think
it's an issue of confidence too I mean
if someone like so looked I worked for a
big evil media Corporation they said
well I said no and they were like play
balls like No And they offered me a lot
of money I was like I don't care dude
how you know look
I have confidence in myself and I know
what I need and so I guess the issue is
perhaps some people are
evil and some people aren't and the evil
activates only in certain capacities
that is when presented with power with
it with with power that they could gain
so for me
you know uh if I was the way I often
describe it is if you're buck naked in
the middle of the woods that's Baseline
that's zero you have nothing but you're
actually not dying you're just you know
you're slowly heading towards a dark
place now if you're buck naked in the
middle of the woods you got a pointy
stick now you're up you're up one so you
actually got something there for all of
us here in this country we're at like 17
million because even as poor as you are
you've got you you're standing on a
street corner the government's going to
give you you got you got clean running
water available to you you walk into
McDonald's you get clean running water
you've got government services up the
Wazoo they're just giving people free
stuff so it's like we are so far
detached from Baseline in this country
there was I you're rich just being here
that's how that's how I I I've always
seen it I think that makes sense I feel
like that too like when you walk into
the grocery store do you ever walk into
the grocery like uh so I used to do a
lot of acid and I would go to the
groceries
all right Ian well whatever but I'd go
to the grocery store and I'd be like the
Bounty here is unbelievable I mean it's
just so much so that there is called
when you look at that when you look at
how much we have in this country like
it's it's very humbling and I think that
has so that so that is gratitude so so
that's beautiful that your State of
Consciousness experiences gratitude many
people do not expect it's not just that
like Tim you were saying maybe some
people are just evil and I think very
fully that all of us are capable of
being the most evil horrible people that
the world has ever seen and you have to
recognize this you have to recognize
your capability for a total total horror
for total evil to be just the worst
person possible and then you have to be
like okay I am capable of this we are
all capable of this that's a very
humbling place to be and then you go
about not using it and you find the
light and you I completely disagree you
go with the light I I I I don't think
every person is capable of evil perhaps
a lot of people are I think that evil is
inherent I mean I think that I think
that I don't I think there's I think
they're sociopaths and I think a lot of
people can't even justify or rationalize
and understand what the bigger
politicians and people in charge are
doing because they can't see themselves
doing it uh themselves I I see what you
guys are saying but I'll see what you
like when you see people that you love
right when you see people who you love
treat other people just absolutely
evilly and with horror like just
horribly and you know like I love this
person this person is capable of love
and they're treating this other person
who I also care about like so terribly
you can see how badly this can turn out
you can see how they mean it I think I
think when you're talking about is a
disowned Shadow right so you're saying
to recognize that in yourself you have
to recognize that and beat it yeah well
you just have to be humble to the in the
face of that I think you just have to
know what I I I think in glory using
things yeah I don't think so so if you
so typically when you have like a family
member mistreating a family member they
don't think they're a bad guy
mistreating a family member they might
you know like maybe you've got a dad
who's yelling at your sister well the
dad is yelling at her and and uh and I'm
talking about in a typical family
context not an abusive context like if
if there's a father who is mercilessly
beating his child congratulations you
found the evil person right I don't
think every human is capable of being
that way I think every human is capable
of it I don't think every I don't think
every human succumbs to it I don't think
there are you know I but I think that
everyone is capable of being a monster
in some form or another I think everyone
is capable of that yeah I think some
some people are and some people aren't I
I think some people are completely
incapable of being that monster well
there's also something called cluster B
right which anti-personality disorder
narcissistic borderline all that stuff
so yeah so there's levels there's levels
to all of this right there's levels of
trauma that you've experienced as a kid
your upbringing
um the fact that you know 100 years ago
people might be reading the Bible
they're probably not now there's there's
a lot to this it's a very Perhaps
Perhaps the argument is you're saying
people many people have Evil Within them
and they have to fight against those
urges I think that would describe people
who have Evil Within them but I think
there are certainly people who aren't
evil I think that it's I think I don't
have a hard time resisting a greater
risk of succumbing to evil if you don't
recognize the human susceptibility to it
I guess what I'm saying is I think
they're I think some people are evil and
perhaps many of them resist the urges to
be evil and do evil and there's varying
degrees to which they are suppressed
from that some is by threat of physical
Force against them why they don't go
into the great grocery store full of
bounty and just take whatever they want
as they know someone will tackle them
and they'll get arrested well not these
days
and that's and that's because some
people are willing to engage in Acts of
let's say outright selfishness except
for physical deterrent some people have
social emotional deterrent meaning
they're scared they will be shunned and
ridiculed if they do it well some people
just genuinely don't want to do it right
and you but you're capable of it I don't
want to do I'm saying I I I think I
think you're confusing the action with
like the desire which is what I'm
talking about I'm saying someone who has
absolutely no desire to commit evil is
sir I I guess they could decide one day
like I've never tried evil but then
they're clearly capable what about the
low-level flunkies and authoritarians
stay States who go ahead and commit the
evil acts on behalf of you know the
authority in their in their country and
they just do it anyway like when you
look at the you know you look at like
the low level yeah
that's evil yeah and there were there
was one guy who crossed his arms and
refused to salute Hitler yeah I don't
think every single person is capable of
it even if you don't go for it I think
you're making the argument about the the
disconnect we're having is that you're
making an argument about the physical
capabilities versus what I'm saying is
the internal desires correct yeah you
don't have to have the design there's
clearly a range of people some again
some people cluster B some people
traumatize some people selfish some
people are more inclined towards it than
others one thing that I will say that I
agree with you a lot is that some people
that I've met in my life they're like oh
I could never do that I could never do
that and then they totally do it so it
would have actually served them to have
that conversation with themselves that
you're talking about well I think it's
important to have that conversation I'm
not talking about uh physical capability
I'm talking about internal desire
some people have no internal desire and
are not at risk of being evil people
well even if you don't have the desire
you
give it there's something
you recognize how good it makes you feel
to be altruistic to have integrity to
add value and then what starts to happen
when you recognize that and you have a
transformation there then you actually
lose those good feelings when you do bad
things so you actually have an internal
regulation because you realize that
you're Contracting and shrinking when
you act like that so you and you can
actually take very dark people and
expose them to that and they can have a
change but they'll they'll often
resisted them yeah they can have
Redemption yeah because we're all
capable of that as well
that's kind of what I meant about some
people from early in the conversation
even if they're not going to do it but
always a chance
so I guess the way I see it is there are
some people
who you know in my experience have been
like that's really cool man like I hope
things are great I have one friend who
is like very Lefty and like still one of
my best friends and they're just like I
don't care about anything else like
you're you're my friend and like we
don't really ever talk about any
hardcore political stuff even though I
see what their posts on social media are
and there are some people who are like
legit hang out everyday best friends who
were never political and then all of a
sudden were like oh now's my chance to
get famous and make money I'm like
clearly one person is evil and one
person is not and the person I see as uh
not evil is political Lefty values but
they're based on ignorance so there's
you know there
they're not I'll put it this way they're
not overtly political going out and
joining activists or anything they're
just posting memes and stuff and they
don't they don't know better and so I
suppose in that sense you could say
there's a capability of the banality of
evil which I understand and would agree
with but I think there are certainly
people who are legitimately and
genuinely evil maybe the better way to
put it is yes everybody is capable of
evil but there are some people who are
downright evil and only being stopped by
committing evil acts due to fear of
physical suppression I think that's true
too your analysis too of like some
people fiscal suppression some people
ridicule some people have ethics and
morals and there's a range of different
people but like a lack of desire to be
evil you know there's some people who
are just like I have no interest
whatsoever and but you know what's funny
about that there's even a range to that
I think Jordan Peterson talks about this
where it's like you see some of these
people that are very very passive like
they're very very chill but then they're
the same people that will vote for a
lockdown right so it's one of these
things where
um Jordan Peterson will say that you
have to be dangerous to even be
trustworthy like be dangerous but then
don't use it so it's one of these things
where how much proactive Consciousness
does someone even have in their mind
mind maybe how much are they even in
touch with their own thinking I think
maybe we're defining evil differently I
suppose but it's it's interesting to
think about like somebody who would be
you know Pro lockdown right and they're
just kind of passive and they're not
really digging into it like I don't know
it's all good like like when I see
people that are easily bent I don't
trust them people that are easily bent
scare me because they're the people that
will be weaponized by some psycho and
then and then what the psycho will do is
shift the Overton window to say oh this
is good and this is bad and then the
past of people are just like okay just
following orders and like to me that's
evil I view it I view it like this in in
the way you mentioned it like what
amount of value on the table would make
you uneasy and for me it's like
literally none like like there could be
you know billions of dollars and I just
be like I don't know but you're an
exceedingly principal I mean I mean you
Luke like and I'm just getting to know
you but I bet you you are the same from
what I mean like Luke has run into riots
in Hong Kong you know with a gas mask on
to go reveal the truth that's not an
average person you've done similar types
of things that's a very different type
of person like there is no circumstance
at any point where if I found a wallet
in it I would take the cash out and
check the wallet no I'm the same way so
why are you like that that's right I
don't know because I know there's
reasons though because I don't like
I somebody needs that wallet back yeah
it's also that you understand that that
you're being a piece of crap and that
would lower your self-esteem
it's not just that it's like I've been
homeless before you know so you have a
higher degree of empathy
it's not even that it's like dude your
money does nothing for me it it moves me
in no way so maybe what you're saying is
that once you reach Financial abundance
no no I'm saying that like I don't want
to be involved with you I'm saying that
I would rather dig through the dirt to
find bugs to eat than have anything to
do with you like I don't want to be
responsible for other people I don't
want to take for them and be responsible
for their misfortunes misdeeds or
fortunes leave me alone let me do my
thing I'll figure it out so for you it's
about self-efficacy it's about
it's it's about in in infringing upon
another person I don't want the
responsibility I don't wanna I don't I
don't wanna hold your kid like you come
with your baby I'll be like I I your kid
is very beautiful very cute I'm very
happy for you I don't want that
responsibility sorry I just so you just
really really like to do your own thing
I like to be left alone and I don't want
to be responsible for other people
um yeah and then it's an interesting
predicament you know running a company
and and having to be because that's a
natural part of reality but my point is
like I would rather be homeless foraging
for food than stealing someone's wallet
or exploiting their Misfortune for me I
wouldn't take the wallet because I think
life is a test on your morality and you
will be judged based on your behaviors
so that's why I wouldn't do it
personally myself and to add you to the
context of what you were saying here MLK
always of course has this famous quote
saying in the end we will remember not
the words of our enemies but the Silence
of our friends and I think that's where
you're kind of getting into and talk
let's go let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com we gotta have a election we
got a lot of election stuff to talk
about we'll talk about the members only
uncensored unfamily friendly show
that'll be at about 10 45 11 pm you
don't want to miss it don't forget to go
to losing mymind.com and check out our
latest song by genocide by Tim cast on
iTunes if you really really want to help
us out we're hoping to smash into the
Billboard Hot 100 maybe we did really
well last time maybe we'll do even
better this time but only with your help
and we do really do appreciate it let's
read your super chats
all right let's see what we got
the Bob says night of the final day 12
hours remain very excellent Donnie Darko
reference that that that that made us
another movie too but that works for
Donnie Darko too right
that was quite a film yeah
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim blood moon
last time 175 days Barbie Pooch
discovered 183 days okay US dollar
official bifocals invented pay money for
bifocals okay uh someone mentioned May
16th the last blood moon was when Sweden
and uh declared the end of their
neutrality they'd be joining NATO that's
wild I saw you pull that wow yeah yeah
very interesting
zorark draft
Zoroark graft the blood moon is an omen
of war in most cultures I believe this
election will be the official lines in
the sand then war will begin the scary
thing here is this this article the
bulwark wrote
they said long story short
poll watchers from both sides are in our
polling station someone thinks someone's
doing something untoward scuffle breaks
out fight breaks out someone gets shot
that's their scenario I go a little bit
further and say if they do they shut
down the polling location and then
there's lawsuits over whether or not you
can actually have the election if a
polling location is shuttered and maybe
violence happens all over it could you
know there could be like we saw in we
saw this kind of demonstrated in V for
Vendetta One Life lost Sparks an entire
outrage we saw it also with George Floyd
So Anything could happen in one instant
and really uh blow things up in a very
bad way
two fails says I've been posting losing
my mind everywhere I can including the
Discord server for Studio file remember
them I got a temporary ban for shared
content featuring controversial
political figure
who's not a controversial political
figure NBA players are all controversial
political figures
yeah yeah yeah all right crazy savior
says oh look no notification the night
before the midterm elections can't say
I'm surprised I didn't get one either
that's right I will also say last month
was the biggest month Tim cast irrell
ever had which is really really cool
news I guess it was bigger than August
2020 which was the the previous biggest
month it was crazy so thank you all so
much for watching we've had a lot of
views this past month thanks y'all
despite the lack of uh notifications
all right what do we got
dreams of a strange man says hello Tim I
appreciate what you do while I don't
agree with you on some things your
channel and Company is important I hope
your growth continues add infinitum
thank you very much I appreciate it
all right what do we got
Tim Paul says hey Tim I think you
thought I was trolling you last time but
I wasn't it really it's really weird but
true I wrote a song called it must be
true with the same concept as losing my
mind uploaded a few weeks ago I didn't
think you're trying I thought you were
being serious yeah
the line says Tim make make us a three
by five stand your ground flag I'll hang
it from the front of the garage love the
design would buy a velcro patch for my
vest too I think we have flags do we
maybe uh if you the stand your ground
sure it is in the chat right now if you
go to timcast.com and click store
there's the uh stand your grants a
rooster oh cute yeah because roosters
will sacrifice themselves to uh give
their hands a chance to escape that's
right yeah they won't give up they will
they will rush into battle knowing they
will die if it means that the hands have
even but an extra second to escape how
about that very Noble be like the noble
rooster refuse to back down
you must stand
voice of the people says you cannot
stand on moral High ground with those
that have no morals the only way they
learn is to do to them what they do to
you the only difference is to stop when
they learn as they would as they would
keep attacking
hmm
let's see
Duncan Chestnut says you don't
neutralize an acid with water use a base
sometimes you gotta dish it back a
little to bring it back all to the
center
my attitude is just
people who are actively trying to
destroy Free Speech get no sympathy from
me when they get censored for violating
the rules they advocated for I think
it's just simple and I don't want to
apply my principles to other people have
you ever read The Sermon on the Mount in
the Bible that'd be interesting what's
it about oven talks all about this great
detail what and what does it say well
it's this is really really heady stuff
right so you can see it at the surface
he talks about forgiveness and it
doesn't seem practical on the surface
but it's coming from a mindset that dark
energy is infecting the world and then
if we keep amplifying it by kind of
reacting back and forth that it grows so
there's a way to absorb it but still
exert leadership that could remove that
energy and then bring peace and that's a
big part of the sermon on the mountain X
says Tim your vengeful cancellation is
off right wrong I have not called for a
vengeful cancellation I have not called
for the Banning of my enemies I have
simply said the people who have sought
to destroy Free Speech will get no
advocacy from me that's neutrality on
the issue whereas other people who have
made nasty political arguments even
those against me I would advocate for
their restoration my point is if you
come out and call me Dom and insult me
and say I'm stupid and have bad ideas
and then you get banned for it I'll be
like no no no come on come on come on
they're allowed to say those things
people in the chat who insult me all day
and night I'll say no no they're allowed
to do it the Only Rule we have is
against spamming because that's actually
anti-speech it makes it impossible for
people to communicate so we have
anti-spam as a rule anything that seeks
to silence people's ability someone who
is seeking to silence the ability of
people to speak actively and encouraging
it I will not call for them to be banned
they're allowed to advocate for it when
they do get banned because of their own
rules I will not advocate for their
restoration I'll simply ignore it and
move on so it's not Revenge it's just
I'm not getting involved
all right Carlos Danger says ligma
Johnson and Deez Nuts MD in 2024. yeah I
mean those are politicians you could
believe in right there great running
Derek Gentry says Libby is wrong the
thinking that thinking is why liberals
keep winning you can't sit on your hands
while five people are hitting you and
expect to win
I said that was pacifism
what was not that's what pacifism is
yeah I don't think you I don't think you
back to that I think you just you just
defined what it was yeah that is what
pacifist means the Advil says Quaker
view yeah they use our principles to
gain power then abuse us with that power
we must fight back and we all know if
you find yourself in a fair fight your
tactics suck
yeah I think of it like borders right I
believe in borders because if you don't
have strong borders you don't have a
country that's literally what defines uh
uh I think we talked about this before I
can't remember which one it was but
nation and country are are different uh
nation is a people with shared ideas
morals or something like that or is it
the other way around I know are there
different meanings one one involved
specifically that there is a border
delineating where these ideas persist if
you have no borders and anyone can come
then your culture eventually dissolves
you can't enforce your own laws someone
could like run in smack you and then run
out and it's like I I guess you if you
don't believe in borders you could go
over there and and arrest them or
something but you need to be able to be
like this is the area that we defend
where we uphold our rights over there we
have no power no control and we're not
going to impose our power on you that's
why I am anti-interventionist but anyway
let's move on
all right
zorrock Graf says both of the guests
tonight clearly don't know who Ethan
Klein is like you guys just came into
the conversation no no Ethan's made
videos about me and so sassan and I'm
chill with it you don't know his history
and who he is and has always been since
he started YouTube well I know that he's
not a political guy and that he's only
involved in politics because it became
pop culture so that that's an issue
right there if I'm having a political
debate with someone who's involved in
politics yeah we can disagree and that's
fine we're trying to solve our problems
but somebody whose whole whole uh career
was edgy comedy and drama videos
deciding that politics is a path towards
making money and being relevant that
person has no interest in a real
conversation so you can invite them all
you want it's meaningless they won't do
it so as he said flat out you go to La
he's not going to meet you he I've been
ignored by him uh
and as for Hassan himself I think I
offered and that was where the
conversation ended and didn't move
forward so I don't know exactly what the
circumstances there was but they do
maybe a zoo and didn't Crowder do a zoom
one with them yeah we don't we don't
that would be providing so we don't have
any capability for Zoom or Skype here we
we actually don't have any any cameras
that can hook up or be so like I
actually have you know like uh Andy Noah
and Lauren Southern wanted to come on
the show remote I said we can't do it we
literally do not have the capability and
we're not going to build it it also
became a screaming match which was a
shame too what did um I think with
Crowder they were just yelling at each
other well because when when Ethan
agreed to have conversation with Crowder
he subbed in Sam Cedar right which is
again it's all about shock drama no real
conversation yeah Steven says either you
don't have a conversation says yes and
then he brings in Sam Cedar and they
turn it into WWE well I know you don't
like LA but I hope to invite you there
someday and show you around and
hopefully you can meet up with even
where I have absolute respect and a
refusal to come on the show is that
they're also media personalities who are
running their own businesses and they're
under no obligation to cancel their
shows to come see me and I understand
stand that because I do the same thing
granted we have the mobile studio for
the purpose to go and try and
accommodate that but when I reached out
to a couple of these people and said hey
like you know people don't want to come
on the show no matter how many times we
offer and it's still to this day the
same same circumstance I invited uh
politics girl I don't know if you're
familiar said we'd love to have you on
the show and have a real conversation
about where we disagree they hit us back
and said what you know what are you
thinking I responded they just dropped
it ignored us outright that is how it
goes every single time you are also a
very formidable debate opponents so it's
one of these things that they might be a
little intimidated too I mean maybe I
don't really debate you know even even
that point you're like maybe you're a
very famous probably intimidating okay
they're invited to have it come and have
a conversation and prove me wrong if I'm
wrong about certain things but what ends
up happening for the most part is here's
what I think happens a lot people on the
right come here and often tell me I'm
wrong about something I may disagree and
then find out I'm actually wrong people
on the left come here and say a whole
bunch of things that are wrong and then
it gets frustrating when we have to keep
pulling up sources to prove that they're
wrong well the challenges that
inherently with collectivism is that the
truth oriented around what will benefit
the collective so it makes it
challenging for them to you know
maintain that under scrutiny well I'll
tell you I'll tell you exactly why they
won't come on the show Hunter Avalon he
came on were you here for that yeah I
wasn't on I wasn't officially as a as a
co-host then but you're just as a guest
I I know oh yeah I was watching right
yeah yeah I was just coming through I
wasn't even supposed to be on he came on
the show he's a guy who used to be
anti-suw conservative and then became
liberal after being awakened by liberals
or something and I I we we invited him
on just like yeah sure you'll be great
to have somebody on and talk about stuff
and I said you can watch the episode but
I said something like look when when
Biden said you know if you don't fire
the prosecutor knocking the billion
dollars I'm like quid pro quo he goes
that didn't happen
and I was like yeah I did it's on videos
no it didn't but I didn't say that
happened hold the video up and he
watched it and he was like I didn't know
that and I'm like you're gonna sit here
and and talk big about the stuff and you
didn't that is a horribly embarrassing
moment they know if they come on the
show it will be the same thing we've
invited even friendly leftists you know
look I don't mean to drag shoe on head
because I'm a fan I think she was great
but we invited her to come on with Alex
Jones to do a big funny show and she
agreed at the last minute she said no
and and I will say I think the reason is
she would be forced to agree with most
of what Alex Jones had to say and that
would be really really bad for her now
she's anti-establishment pro-free speech
all these really really awesome things
that I agree with and I think she's
great she calls out the left and a lot
of stuff but it is challenging even if
you're in and any even left libertarian
space to be seen on camera with Alex
Jones uh there there are a few other
leftists that were fans of and I'm not
going to try the only reason I bring up
shoe is because that one we've already
publicly talked about people have
tweeted about it there's a few other
leftists who invited who were we like
and we're fans of who have said the same
thing I can't appear on a show with
people like that it's like okay I get it
you don't want to you your your
principles are not as important as you
looking bad for your people but it's
also that inherently in collectivism
they warp the truth to try to to try to
benefit the collective so it makes it
hard to debate against somebody like you
because you're just like a very
practical person like I just want to be
left alone I want to know the truth they
have truths that are based on what they
perceive as the collective benefit so
then it makes it very difficult
everybody has varying degrees of
collectivism that's true you know the
right has there has is to a lesser
degree but they certainly do have it
especially the 90s oh yeah I mean but
but these days there's a weird merger of
like a lot of a lot of I think a lot of
Ron Paul libertarian types uh event they
went to Occupy Wall Street they ended up
becoming Maga you know they they want to
be leave the world alone focus on
America work hard mind our own business
you know let's read let's read more uh
super chats
Michael Irwin says blood moon tomorrow
looks like even God is voting red LOL
also no notification and bad to search
for you tonight to had to search for you
to find it yep you know there you go man
all right Ethan Sacco says Ethan Klein
gives Ethan's around the world a bad
name let's come up with a new name for
him in the comments section uh h3h3 how
about that one which column what is a
brand name there you go I say l303 L3 L3
l303 yeah for like lose yeah basically
all right toxic way says Tim what you
say about adding credibility meter to
verified accounts something akin to
newsguard absolutely not uh I disagree I
think the jester cap or some kind of
Comedy icon newsguard has that it's a
theater mask in Orange so if you go to a
parody site it tells you it's a parody
site I actually like that or you know to
tell them who um the advertisers are you
know big Pharma sponsors 80 of this news
Outlet you should that would actually be
very useful that's a great idea yeah
yeah have transparency with where the
money's coming from so we know that
they're not going to buy bite the hand
that feeds that would have been very
useful during the pandemic absolutely
with the New York Times yeah some people
have asked what's going on with our our
fact checking news thing it's we've
we're filing uh truth and media
foundation and we're going to do
articles of fact checking things like
that and it takes a really long time to
organize it's incredible so I think we
got like the last bit of the paperwork
in but where we get we go back and forth
with the government to certify a
non-profit and do all this stuff so it
is what it is but that's a really good
idea yeah a browser extension that not
only fact checks but shows you who their
sponsors are and it can break down like
we randomly sampled 100 ads uh 100
articles we fact checked them and these
are the ads that were posted Bill Gates
paid for this much of these uh articles
you know oh there's a great article
about Bill Gates that's private
information that's harder what we can do
is say 17 displayed ads from the Google
Network which were algorithmic 17 were
Coca-Cola seven percent were Pfizer 23
or depends diapers whatever but Bill
Gates spends hundreds of millions of
dollars investing it specifically in the
corporate media that reports on them as
some kind of great savior coincidence
I thought that video you posted this
morning was crazy with the CIA guy from
the 80s yep it was Glenn I think no no
no Snowden yeah Edward Snowden from
Russia I think I saw it when you but
I've talked about this yeah that's
exactly what I said I said this a couple
months ago that what happens is that's
true I I said this a month ago not even
that yeah or a couple weeks ago yeah we
had a conversation not so long ago the
government goes to these young
journalists and says I'm Gonna Be Your
Source now they do it for influencers
too right and now all of a sudden you
have this young journalist who's writing
for say like Business Insider with like
an entry level position starts writing
some articles claiming Trump is involved
with Russia or whatever the editor at
the company gets like wow how are you
getting this I got a government Source
the government goes to a young person
who's too stupid to realize they're
being fed BS the newspaper doesn't care
because hey it came from a legitimate
government source so we can run it we
can't be sued then we get a bombshell
story and make money then this person
gets promoted they get hired by a bigger
Outlet than they get put on TV and they
still have their same garbage Source
that's right yeah they fake news for the
intelligence agencies like the New York
Times they're like oh yeah wwmds in Iraq
100 yeah anonymous source track media
only says allowing Ethan and Kathy back
on Twitter as like a cashless bail
they've already had third and fourth
chances if not more and you still want
to let them out yes but only insofar as
they're actively destroying free speech
like uh Milo Alex Jones that you should
be allowed back on even if you broke the
rules however what I'm saying is if you
Advocate that people should not be
allowed back on I will not advocate for
you to be allowed back on I'm not saying
you shouldn't be allowed back I'm saying
I'm not going to intervene that's all
you man yeah you will not get any any
favors for me but it could be a gesture
of Goodwill that could maybe potentially
I'm being very uh optimistic here and
and maybe even for Jesus maybe he's like
wow these guys are actually fighting for
me when I was a such a you know bad word
against them who is who is that guy in
Philly it was a Soros D.A he he they
fought to get him out of jail or was it
no no no no there was a guy in prison
they fought to get him out of prison it
made me crazy they fought to get him out
of prison because they were like do you
what what did fetterman say about this
he said do you think Morgan Freeman in
uh Shawshank Redemption should die in
prison because there are a lot of people
in prison who who you know should be let
out they let this guy out he kills again
yep so it's kind of like you think these
people are going to change their ways to
show you who they are I mean Kamala
Harris uh funded a bail fund that let a
guy out who then went on to kill people
more you know it's like what happens we
have a very important Super Chat here
Matthew Matthew Schneider says Trump is
really an Uchiha and the blood moon is
his tsukiyomi to get people to vote
Republican he's still speaking right I
have to I have to I have to explain it
to everybody
bouncing stuff off other people he's
just talking the whole time yeah I have
to explain this to people who don't
understand uh Uchiha is a clan in Naruto
who have eyes called the Sharingan which
means in Japanese copy wheel eye and the
tsukiyomi is a powerful technique that
allows them to hypnotize you and by
portraying his eye on the moon it can
make everyone in the world hypnotized
and follow and that's basically the plot
of Naruto so there you go that was the
that was the esoteric joke for those
that didn't get it
all right let's see where we're at
dreams of a strange man says
hey Luke hey Luke will hate this I
searched Chicken on Walmart's app and
most of it was canned and crap and some
of the search results were dried black
soldier fly larva it's disgusting I had
to scroll way down to get fresh chicken
why would locate that just don't I like
I like fresh food real food and beef
liver Wally Higgins says Tim is right
you should not Advocate on behalf of
people who hate you you should not
compromise with people that hate you
it's a losing strategy
yeah
lizard says the blood moon also means
that vampires are coming in Romania in
Romanian Traditions beware
vampires are coming tax agents
yeah the IRS is going to come out it'd
be funny if Biden came out and they
announced or it would be funny it was
Kamala that in order to make things more
efficient the IRS would only be coming
out at night in the wheels of the
morning and they can't enter your house
unless you give them permission wow
sounds like vampires that sounds like a
that sounds like a role I would get
behind they're just waiting outside your
door and like get out of here
they're like give us your money no
okay where are we at what's big Super
Chat thank you appreciate it Jen that's
uh Desai says did you see the American
flags blow down at fetterman rally and
the double rainbow for mastriano now the
Maga Moon that was pretty crazy there
was a double rainbow from estriano yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and those flags just
went right down and I think Trump was
speaking at that same rally Trump's
still speaking he's still speaking right
now I'm watching the live stream so
we're he's gonna announce he's got to
he's been going for so long how long
when did he start I mean it's been an
hour at least since the first time
Maybe
that guy can talk for a long time yeah
yeah he loves it it energizes yeah yeah
he gets a lot of power energize the
crowds Shannon Shannon says playing the
lottery is a tax on people who can't do
math
I I disagree you know
uh it's all about being responsible with
gambling like if you buy a quick pick
once a week because it it's fun and
you're like you know you want to look at
the numbers and it's really exciting to
see the numbers get counted that's
totally fine like you know people say oh
the lottery is a text on stupid people
No gambling exploits people who have
gambling problems but I go to the casino
fairly often we do we go we go we go
every so often and it's like you go to
the casino
you you set a budget of how much you
want to play with and then you have
entertainment and if you're lucky
somebody's casinos offer free drinks so
you're basically like my drinks are paid
for as I gamble so I'm basically
spending money on the night to just have
fun and sometimes you get a little extra
money sometimes you break even sometimes
you lose you tend to lose I lost 80 in
Las Vegas that way but I also had seven
drinks so I mean there you go but it's
also like don't go to a casino thinking
you're gonna win a million dollars you
go there to hang out and feel the
excitement of like are you gonna get a
blackjack whoa I got it and everyone
cheers and it's fun or you get like
trips in poker or something I also watch
somebody lose literally I think like
eighteen thousand dollars sitting next
to me and that was terrifying yeah that
was terrifying it's also a good lesson
on not doing that yeah so I look at the
lottery and it's like bro if you make
like 20 bucks an hour and then you'd
spend your entire paycheck on lottery
tickets like that that's a problem but
I'm not going to advocate for the
government to stop you from being able
to do it but if you go and you like
today I saw a guy he put 10 bucks down
and it was five games five Quick Picks
and I'm like that's that's fun he's
gonna be go back and he's gonna you know
sit on the couch and he's gonna be
hanging out with his wife or whatever
and they're gonna be smiling and they're
like ooh just having that dream and then
they're going to go back to their lives
and they're going to crumple it up in
fact winning would probably be worse for
him it'd be better for him in the sense
that they get health care and be taking
care of her life but man the emotional
turmoil that would come from that win is
is scary yeah not everybody can handle
it
uh Rogue gaming says each moon is named
three moons per season in a year with 13
full moons one season with four moons
has the blue moon it is the second or
third out of the of the four full moons
in that season
oh interesting I thought the blue moon
was the second full moon in one month
so that like yeah I don't know because
typically it's like every 28 days so
then every so often you'll get a Blue
Moon which is two full moons in one
month I don't know maybe I'm wrong
all right let's grab some I wonder if uh
you know in Miami they have like full
moon parties I wonder what their party
is for the blood moon yeah la too yeah
there's a lot of Full Moon parties yeah
like the local world that I've been to
that are pretty yeah they see that I
went to one recently in September it was
a lot of fun yeah all right we'll get
one more here Raymond g Stanley Jr says
Tim for long show he got coming tomorrow
um who do we have coming should we
announce oh yeah there's something crazy
Olivia will be here I'm gonna be around
I think uh uh so so what I understand is
who's coming jewelry and as we'll be
here we're excited Drew's cool uh Lisa
Reynolds will be coming back oh nice
we're gonna have those guys both of them
yeah Mary Morgan will be hanging out
then uh Owen's gonna be here as well yep
but we're gonna have the room full and
then of course the entire Tim cast crew
whoever wants to come we're gonna be
basically hanging out here partying all
day so we'll probably start the stream
we might start it early maybe six
depending on what happened look if
something crazy happens we'll we'll
we'll we'll run up here we'll get
something going let's keep it eye on it
and call it when we're we're there
downstairs so we'll be there down like
four or five o'clock hanging out we'll
be paying attention something breaks
we're running up here yeah yeah yeah and
then we're basically just gonna chill
and have people come in and come out and
uh because it's it's it's it's an it's a
nail biter night man yeah all right if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this share with your
friends and become a member over at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only show coming up for you we'll talk a
bit about the election some other stuff
you can follow us at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast and if you really
really want to support us we're hoping
to smash into the Billboard Hot 100 with
your help buying Our Song genocide
losing my mind on iTunes or anywhere
else we're currently I well we earlier
today we're all weekend the number one
best-selling song on Amazon music we hit
number one on iTunes displacing Taylor
Swift Friday and Saturday but drop down
on Sunday but um I'm feeling pretty good
we don't have as many views on this one
on YouTube but it looks like streaming
and per and sales are way better on this
song we got way more likes on this one
I'm hoping that next week Tuesday when
the billboard comes out we're gonna
we're gonna be in the hot 100. the goal
is just to make make music make culture
but also to eventually start pushing
them out of these spaces so much like
the daily wire is doing movies and shows
we want to make more and more cultural
stuff too so with your support we can uh
Libby do you want to shout anything out
uh yeah so I'm wearing this learn to
code shirt actually that it's hate
speech and you could buy it actually my
friend and I have this
wokestore.me and you could check it out
yeah it's actually it's pretty cool so
and also I'm up at the post millennial
every day right on Owen so you remember
we were talking about weird coincidences
earlier I know you weren't too sold on
it but I'll show you something funny
I'll pull out my text message later I'm
just not told on the meaning totally get
it so the thing is um I'm going to show
you the text message later but the video
that we were planning to post tonight
was all about this topic and I rarely
ever talk about this it's a video I shot
it in Yellowstone National Park it's
like a one-hour documentary all about
the idea of forgiveness and I was
planning to post it before we even came
here and it's perfectly suited so if you
go to Owen Cook's self-help Owen Cook
self-help on YouTube go subscribe and
there's a ton of incredible personal
growth content on there but specifically
I'm gonna go post this video from
Yellowstone we shot in a beautiful
winter in Lamar Valley in Yellowstone
for about almost an hour just on this
topic and uh I think it's going to be a
perfect follow-up just for what we
talked about here so interesting
coincidence there thank you guys so much
for coming this was great I love the
conversation my website is Luke
uncensored.com I have a lot of amazing
members on there you could talk to them
you could talk to me all on that website
I did a video today just for members
talking about my predictions for this
upcoming election and I think it's
definitely worth the watch check it out
on lukeansensored.com
and I'm search.com guys there's a lot of
fakes out there saying they're me it
serves.com that's me the only one so uh
one last thought before we go into the
members only show which I encourage you
to come and watch ABC news says a red
Mirage or an artificial GOP vote lead
will likely reoccur on Tuesday okay
we're going to talk about that over at
timcast.com we'll see you there thanks
for hanging out cheers